This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。保证真人。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯瑟。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇妙的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是字母开头的TWO。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利西。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《look back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话——在其他任何地方进行这些对话其实都不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就。就一定要用它。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《learn the hard way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了大批人马，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己动手。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we welcome back one of our favorite, my favorite guests. She has been on the show so many times. She is one of the global experts on attachment style, relationships, how to find healthy love. She's written two books. She has coached thousands of people and has done more research on this than probably any other person. The other day, I got an email from her
我是吉玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个与大家畅谈二十几岁时最大的改变、重要时刻和人生转变，以及这些对我们二十几岁的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目。今天，我们迎来了我们最喜欢的、也是我最喜欢的嘉宾之一。她已经上过这个节目很多次了。她是关于依恋类型、人际关系以及如何找到健康爱情的全球顶尖专家之一。她写了两本书。她指导过成千上万的人，在这方面的研究可能比任何其他人都多。前几天，我收到了她的一封电子邮件
about this new theory that she's been working on. It's called the six stages of a relationship. And I just knew we had to talk about it because it is incredibly accurate. First of all, it is so accurate how it represents almost every relationship we find ourselves in. And I also think that learning about these six stages, especially in our 20s, what they represent, what they mean could help us all be more realistic about love and also understand the highs and lows of dating and the highs and lows of devotion and being with somebody long term. Without further ado, here she is. Taise Gibson, welcome to the psychology of your 20s again.
关于她一直在研究的一个新理论。它被称为“一段感情的六个阶段”。我立刻就知道我们必须聊聊这个，因为这实在是太准了。首先，它非常准确地反映了我们几乎陷入的每一段关系。而且我也认为，了解这六个阶段，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，了解它们代表什么、意味着什么，可以帮助我们所有人对爱情保持更多现实的期待，同时也能理解约会时的高潮与低谷，以及奉献和长期伴侣关系的高潮与低谷。废话不多说，她来了。泰丝·吉布森，欢迎再次来到《The Psychology of Your 20s》。
Thank you for having me. You're one of my favorite people to chat with and join podcasts with and just honestly catch up with. So it's really nice to be here. No, it's, it's so lovely every time you come on the show. And you've been on a couple of times. You're like my go-to attachment style expert. I love your in-depth knowledge. I love how you talk about these topics. I've kind of spoiled my next question, which is tell the listeners a little bit about yourself and what kind of work you do. Yeah. So to your point, I definitely work in the relationship space. By trade, I am a counselor and coach. And I've been in a space for, quite a while now more than a decade. And I tend to focus a lot in the attachment style space.
谢谢你邀请我。你是我最喜欢聊天、一起上播客以及单纯叙旧的人之一。所以很高兴能来到这里。不，每一次你来节目都非常棒。而且你已经来过好几次了。你就像是我首选的依恋类型专家。我喜欢你深入的见解。我喜欢你谈论这些话题的方式。我有点剧透了我的下一个问题，那就是请向听众简单介绍一下你自己以及你从事什么样的工作。好的。如你所说，我确实在人际关系领域工作。职业上，我是一名咨询师和教练。在这个领域我已经工作相当长一段时间了，超过十年了。而且我往往把很多精力放在依恋类型领域。
And I think that comes from growing up with a fearful avoidant attachment style myself and really pouring into trying to understand how to heal. And I put a huge emphasis and focus not just on like understanding things and intellectualizing things, but actually rewiring. Because the more we can really dig into the subconscious and rewire our patterns and leverage neuroplasticity, that's where you get to see the real healing. change and growth. And so that was something that helped me on my journey so much and something that I'm always really excited to talk about and share with other people. And you do like just the way you talk about it is incredible. And if you haven't listened to our other episodes, I think we did run on anxious
我想这源于我自己成长过程中就有恐惧型回避的依恋类型，并真正投入到试图理解如何疗愈中。我非常强调和关注的不仅仅是理解事物和将事物知识化，而是真正的神经重塑。因为我们越能深入潜意识，重塑我们的模式并利用神经可塑性，你就会看到真正的疗愈。改变和成长。所以这对我自己的旅程帮助很大，也是我一直非常兴奋能与其他人谈论和分享的事情。而且你谈论它的方式简直太不可思议了。如果你还没听过我们之前的节目，我想我们做过关于焦虑型
attachment and avoidant. Very much recommend going and listening to those two of my favorite episodes that we've ever done, to be honest. But today we're going to talk about this, I guess, new theory that you've come up with this new concept that you told me about and I was like, how come no one has ever shared this or talked about this or come up with this before? It is the six-stage theory of relationships. You know, I adore a theory. I adore like any kind of succinct explanation of like human phenomena. Can you just like quickly explain this one for me before we go into each stage individually? Yes. So the theory is essentially that every relationship has six stages. And I saw this through working with tens of thousands of clients that there's essentially a life cycle of every
依恋和回避型的节目。强烈推荐大家去听听那两期节目，老实说，那是我最喜欢的两期节目。但今天要谈的是这个，我猜是你最近提出的新理论，你告诉我这个新概念时，我在想，怎么从来没有人分享过、谈论过或者以前提出过这个理论呢？这就是人际关系六阶段理论。你知道的，我非常喜欢各种理论。我喜欢任何对人类现象的简洁解释。在我们在逐一探讨每个阶段之前，你能先简单地为我解释一下这个理论吗？好的。这个理论基本上是说，每一段关系都有六个阶段。这是我通过与数万名客户合作发现的，基本上每一段关系都有一个生命周期。
relationship. And it starts at a high level. We'll talk about them in detail for sure, but at a high level, the first stage is the dating stage. And the intention of this stage is to really bet and get to know somebody and like, see if they're a good fit for you and vice versa. And then when we make a commitment, we move into the honeymoon stage. And this is the stage where essentially we have a rose color glasses on and we're all excited and everything feels great and it's easy and it's flowing. but we're usually showing ourselves still with a good bit of conditions. We're on our best behavior. We're still people pleasing maybe a little bit more than we otherwise would. We're not as comfortable.
它始于一个宏观层面。我们稍后一定会详细探讨，但从宏观层面来看，第一阶段是约会阶段。这个阶段的目的是真正去了解某个人，看看他们是否适合你，反之亦然。然后，当我们做出承诺时，我们就进入了热恋阶段。这个阶段基本上是我们戴着玫瑰色眼镜，我们都很兴奋，一切感觉都很好，一切都很轻松顺畅。但通常我们在某种程度上仍然带着条件展示自己。我们表现出最好的自己。我们甚至可能比平时更多地讨好他人。我们还没有那么自在。
And then we let down the mask and get comfortable. And that actually is what draws us into the power struggle stage. And the power struggle stage you'll see is where statistically most people break up. But the crazy part is that if you don't realize that in the long grand scheme of an entire relationship, like if you're going to marry somebody and be with them for decades, perhaps, the dating honeymoon power struggle are such a small. snapshot of a whole relationship. And if we don't ever have a relationship that makes beyond the power struggle, then people think that the whole relationship is like this high of infatuation,
然后我们摘下面具，变得自如。而这实际上正是将我们拉入权力之争阶段的原因。你会发现，权力之争阶段是统计学上大多数人分手的阶段。但疯狂的部分在于，如果你没有意识到，在整段关系的宏观蓝图中——比如如果你要和某人结婚并相伴数十年之久的话——约会、热恋、权力之争，这只是整段关系中非常小的一个快照。如果我们从未经历过一段超越权力之争的关系，那么人们就会认为整段关系就像这样充满迷恋的高潮，
this low of fighting and more arguing, and it breaks up. And the reality is that the power struggle stage is actually something that presents this really unique and powerful opportunity to know each other more deeply, to work through conflict, to learn to hash things out, to learn each other and to get into a rhythm. And if we do that, we then progress into future stages. which become the rhythm stage, the devotion stage, and eventually the everlasting stage, which is where we have this true and deep sense of lasting contentment in the relationship. And so we'll boil into all of the stages, of course, in a lot of detail. But the theory essentially is rooted in the fact that every relationship, point blank period,
伴随着争吵和争论不断增加的低谷，然后就分开了。但现实是，权力之争阶段实际上提供了一个非常独特且强有力的机会，让我们能够更深入地了解彼此，解决冲突，学会把事情摊开来讲，了解彼此并进入一种默契的节奏。如果我们做到了这一点，我们就会进入未来的阶段。也就是默契阶段、奉献阶段，最后是永恒阶段，在这个阶段，我们在关系中拥有真实而深厚的持久满足感。所以，我们当然会非常详细地探讨所有阶段。但这个理论的根基实际上在于这样一个事实：每一段关系，毫无例外，
goes through this life cycle, and there are specific rights of passage that we need to move from one stage to the next. So in order to continuously progress, there's actually things we have to tell. learn and get good at with each other. And if we don't learn those rights of passage, we'll actually get stuck in a certain stage. And the longer we're stuck in a stage, without progressing, the more likely the relationship is to end. So what I find to be really meaningful is if people are struggling in relationships and they never really, you know, have a lasting relationship. It's always a year or two years, they break up, you know, things like this. And they're looking for something longer lasting
都会经历这个生命周期，而且我们需要经历特定的“成人礼”才能从一个阶段过渡到下一个阶段。因此，为了不断取得进展，实际上有些事情我们必须学习并与彼此磨合好。如果我们没有学会那些“成人礼”，我们实际上就会被困在某个阶段。我们在一个阶段停留的时间越长而没有进展，这段关系走向终结的可能性就越大。所以，我发现非常有意义的是，如果人们在感情中苦苦挣扎，却从未真正拥有一段持久的关系。总是维持一年或两年就分手，诸如此类。而他们正在寻找更持久、更显著的东西。
and more prominent for them. Or if somebody is in a stage now listening, perhaps and they're like, I feel like I'm stuck in one of these stages and everything's rocking and we're not progressing. It's much less of the time that you have the wrong partner and much more of the time that you instead have the wrong tools and the wrong behaviors and relationships that are actually keeping you stuck and not allowing you to progress. And I would make a really strong argument having seen this firsthand that so often people are like, oh, maybe I'm not compatible with somebody. Oh my gosh, what if it doesn't work out and they feel stuck? And actually, once they get the certain tools that they need to unlock the next stage, things move, move forward much more effortlessly.
或者如果现在正有人在听节目，他们觉得“我觉得自己被困在其中某一个阶段了，一切都停滞不前，我们没有进展”。很多时候，并不是因为你选错了伴侣，而是因为你用了错误的工具和错误的行为，这些关系实际上让你陷入困境，无法继续前进。我根据自己的亲身经历可以提出一个非常有力的论点，那就是人们常常会想，“哦，也许我和某人不合适。天哪，如果行不通怎么办”，然后他们就会感到困惑。但实际上，一旦他们掌握了解锁下一阶段所需的特定工具，事情就会毫不费力地向前推进。
So that's essentially the theory in a nutshell. Which I love. And we were talking before I pressed record and I was like to get to be vulnerable and to be completely honest. Like I'm seeing my current relationship, well my not current, just my relationship. Well, no, my current relationship like reach a new stage that I never have with other partners. And like we've just definitely passed through this like power struggle phase where, you know, we're moving and like we really have to like know each other deeper. And I've never passed through the stage before and I feel like we're getting to the end of it. And this theory has like opened my eyes to all previous relationships that I have ever had.
所以，这就是该理论的精髓所在。我非常喜欢。在按下录音键之前我们就在聊天，我就像去展露脆弱，坦白地说。我看到我目前的恋情，或者说不是目前的，就是我的感情。好吧，不，我的现任感情正达到一个我以前从未与伴侣经历过的新阶段。我们绝对已经度过了这个权力之争的阶段，你知道的，我们在前进，我们真的必须更深入地了解彼此。我以前从未经历过这个阶段，我觉得我们快要走到这一阶段的尽头了。这个理论让我对以前经历过的所有恋情都有了全新的认识。
And every single one of them follows this. And obviously like they break up at different points. But never beyond the rhythm stage have I broken up with someone, which is interesting. And that is almost exactly how it goes for people. So once people I find as a general ballpark, I don't have like really hard data on this. I'm just pulling from like tens of thousands of conversations and clients over the years. But I would say generally you're looking at like 80% chance of the relationship
而且每一段都遵循这个规律。显然，它们在不同的时间点分手了。但从来没有在超越默契阶段之后我才和某人分手的，这很有趣。这几乎就是人们经历的翻版。所以一旦人们——我发现作为一个大致的估算，我没有关于这方面的确凿硬数据。我只是结合了这些年来的数万次对话和客户经验。但我可以说，大体上来看，如果你进入了默契阶段，这段关系有大约80%的几率能够真正长久地持续下去。所以到那个时候，那是因为你已经学会了如何导航，而且随着我们深入探讨权力之争、“成人礼”以及所有这些事情，你会看到
really lasting for the long, long haul if you make it to the rhythm stage. So at that point, it's because you've learned how to navigate and we'll as we dive into the power struggle and the rights of passage and all these things, you'll see. and learn that if we can't get the important lessons right in that stage, that's what makes everything fall apart. But if we get them right in that stage, it's what exactly prepares us for everything to come so that we can thrive and stay connected and know how to weather hard times in the future if we ever go through them or be able to really build roots that are allowing a relationship to thrive and last for the long haul. And I almost think of like a relationship
并了解到，如果我们无法在该阶段正确汲取重要的教训，那正是导致一切分崩离析的原因。但如果我们能在那个阶段做对，这正是为未来的所有事情做好了准备，以便我们能够蓬勃发展、保持联系，并在未来经历艰难时期时知道如何度过，或者能够真正建立起让关系蓬勃发展并长久持续的根基。我甚至会想到人际关系本身。如果有一个视觉比喻，每一段关系就像一棵小树，一棵小树苗。在约会阶段，我们就像是“哦，有一棵小树在生长，我们好兴奋”。然后你给它浇水，它得到阳光，长出稍微深一点的根。我们就像“哇，它在长高”。然后权力之争阶段就像是这棵树遇到的第一场风暴。就像，你知道的，有一场雷雨。如果我们不知道如何度过那个阶段，这棵树可能会被连根拔起。但是，你知道的，如果风真的很大，也许会这样，对吧？
itself. If there was a visual analogy, every relationship's like a little tree, like a little sapling. And in the dating stage, we're like, oh, there's a little tree growing and we're so excited. And then you water it, and it gets sunlight and it builds slightly deeper roots. And we're like, wow, it's growing. And then the power struggle stage is like the first storm that happens for the tree. And it's like, you know, there's a thunderstorm. And if we don't know how to navigate that stage, the tree can get ripped out of the ground. But, you know, if it's really windy, perhaps, right?
但是，如果我们能够随着时间的推移，真正为这棵树建立越来越深的根基并滋养它，最终根基会变得如此深厚，以至于即使发生飓风，这棵树也不会被连根拔起。所以，这才是这一切的关键所在。就像我们如何用正确的工具建立深深的根基？这就是当人们进入永恒阶段时所能做到的。人们在永恒阶段报告说，不仅拥有最长久的感情，而且事实上，他们在感情中感到的满足感也是最高的。有时看到这些会觉得既悲伤又艰难，因为我认为每个人都见过这种情况：你认识生活中的某对情侣，或者也许你们就是那对情侣，
But if we're able to really build deeper and deeper roots and nourish that tree across time, eventually the roots become so deep that even if there's like a hurricane, that tree is not going to come out of the ground. And so that's really what this is all about. It's like how do we build those deep roots with the right tools? And that's what allows people to when they make it to the everlasting stage. People report in the everlasting stage and not just having the longest lasting relationships, of course, but they actually report being the most fulfilled in their relationships. And what's sad and hard to see sometimes is that I think everybody's seen this where you know a couple in your life or maybe you're that couple.
此时此刻，你能看出人们在一起是真正的快乐。他们在一起很久了，但他们确实感到满足。然后你会看到其他情侣，他们在一起，也许结婚了30年。但你能看出他们根本不快乐。他们只是在硬撑，你知道的，他们仍然整天争吵，过得很痛苦。这就好比，这并不是一段成功的感情。这种情况其实是他们从未离开权力之争的阶段。所以人们可以说约会和热恋期有不同的持续时间，但如果人们没有真正学会如何度过权力之争，他们实际上会长期停留在其中。
now and where you can tell people are truly happy together. They've been together a long time, but they're truly fulfilled. And then there's other couples you see where they're together and maybe they're married for 30 years. But you can tell they're just not happy. Like they're just kind of sticking it out and they're just, you know, they're still fighting all the time and they're miserable. And it's like, well, that's not success in a relationship. And what that is is it's actually they never left the power struggle stage. So people can say the dating and honeymoon have different time spans, but the power struggle people can actually stay in. for the long haul if they don't actually learn how to move through it.
好了，我们需要深入探讨这些阶段，因为我觉得我会有太多的问题，但我想：我们先谈谈各个阶段，然后我就可以顺着这个思路继续了。但从第一阶段开始，也就是你必须开始和某人交谈，你必须开始和某人约会。在这个时期，有哪些关键的事情需要注意，它们可能会预示未来的契合度？是的，问得好。所以，在约会阶段，约会阶段通常持续大约零到六个月。
Okay, we need to get into these stages because I feel like I'm going to, I have so many questions, but I'm like, let's talk about the stages first because then I can go from there. But beginning with step one, which is you've got to start talking to someone, you've got to start dating somebody. What are the key things to like look out for during this period that may predict like future compatibility? Yeah, great question. So in the dating stage, the dating stage generally lasts about zero to six months.
根据他们的依恋类型，人们会试图稍微加快这个过程，比如稍微焦虑一点的人，他们会想更快地从约会过渡到热恋，因为通往热恋的“成人礼”更多是关于我们是否决定一起确立恋爱关系，还是我们只是还在互相观察。那些稍微倾向于回避型的人，往往会倾向于：“让我们永远停留在约会阶段吧。”他们会把这个阶段拖得很长，通常更接近六个月的期限。但在约会阶段需要做好准备的真正重要的事情是，第一点。
And it will be, people will try to speed it along a little bit based on their attachment style, like people who are a little more anxious, they'll want to go from dating into honeymoon quicker because the right of passage into honeymoon is more about did we decide to commit to a relationship together, or are we just still seeing each other. People who are a little more avoidant leaning, they'll tend to be like, let's stay in the dating stage forever. They'll really drag it out and usually they're closer to the six month mark. But the really important things to go in prepared for in the dating stage are number one. You have to know what you're looking for.
你必须清楚自己在寻找什么。说实话，我认为人们真的低估了这个阶段及其重要性，因为如果你没有正确地度过约会阶段，就像你试图把一颗种子或农作物种在错误的土壤里一样，对吧？这就好比如果你没有适合作物生长的土壤，你就会举步维艰。我在执业中看到很多人，他们进去后开始约会某人，对约会的标准定得非常低。比如：“我只想找一个我有吸引力、能玩得开心的人。”然后他们开始尝试在约会时赢得对方的芳心。
And truly, I think people really underestimate this stage and how important it is because if you don't do the dating stage properly, it's like you try to plant a seed or a crop that you're trying to grow in the wrong soil, right? It's like if you don't have soil conducive to growing the crop, you're going to have a hard time. And a lot of people that I would see in my practice is they would go in, they would date somebody, they would have very low standards for dating. It would be like, I just want to find somebody I'm attracted to and I have fun with. And then they get into the space of trying to win the person over when they start dating them.
他们会觉得：“哦，我只想让他们喜欢我并愿意对我有承诺。”他们把注意力和重点放在了那里，而不是放在甄别上。而约会阶段的整个目的都是为了甄别，我们一会儿就会谈到这一点。所以他们没有进行甄别。然后因为他们处于这种讨好他人的阶段，试图赢得对方的芳心，当你经历了热恋阶段并进入权力之争阶段时，你并没有为成功做好准备。你会发现你们的所有不合更加明显。
They're like, oh, I just want to get them to like me and want to commit to me. And they put their focus and attention there instead of on vetting. And the entire purpose of the dating stage is about vet, which will come to in a second. so they don't vet. And then because they're in this like people pleasing stage trying to win the person over, by the time you then move through the honeymoon stage and get into the power struggle stage, you're not set up for success. And you're going to see all of your incompatibilities are more glaring.
会有很多挑战。所以针对你的问题，你要做的第一件事是：你必须清楚，我的标准是什么，我在感情中的需求是什么，我的底线是什么？我总是让人们从这里开始。然后真正把这些事情搞清楚。第二个问题——你可能会觉得大家一出门就知道寻找这个，但其实并没有。
There's going to be a lot of challenges. And so the first thing you want to start with to your question is like, you want to know, what are my standards, what are my needs in a relationship, and what are my non-negotiables? And I always get people to start there. and then really get clear about those things. And then the second question, and you would think people know to just look for this right out of the gates, but they don't.
第二个问题是：我应该在哪里寻找这个人？你会对这样的人数感到震惊，他们会说：“哦，我真的很想找一个情感成熟、积极进取的人。”然后我会问：“哦，你一直在哪里找呢？”
The second question is, where should I be looking for this person? Because you'd be shocked at the amount of people who will say things like, oh, I really want to find somebody who's emotionally available and who's working on themselves. And I'm like, oh, where have you been looking?
人们会说：“哦，好吧，我想我每个周五周六晚上都会去酒吧碰碰运气，希望能遇到某人。”并不是说酒吧里没有情感成熟的人。当然会有。只是你把自己找到对的人的几率降到最低了。如果你真的在寻找一段健康的感情，并且试图掌控你人生的约会阶段，我们就需要去寻找——好吧，寻找情感成熟的人，
And people will be like, oh, well, I guess I just kind of go out to the bar every Friday and Saturday and hope to meet somebody. And it's not that there's no emotionally available people at a bar. Of course there will be. It's just that you're minimizing your chances of finding the right person. Like if you're really looking for a healthy relationship and you're trying to master the dating stage of your life, we want to be looking, okay, emotionally available people,
寻找那些积极进取的人。我每周会去当地的个人成长聚会一次左右。我会让受人尊敬的人帮我介绍。正是如此。正是如此。正是如此。所以我们在那个阶段需要有目的性。这使我们能够掌控自己的时间，不浪费自己的时间，并且真正尊重我们的界限，尊重我们在寻找的东西——本质上是我们在这个阶段的标准。一旦我们遇到了感兴趣的人，并且在正确的地方寻找，带着我们有意识寻找的意图，那么在此之下的下一个重大要素就是：你需要去提出那些能够弄清你们是否合拍的问题。
people working on themselves. I'm going to go to like a personal growth meet up in my area once a week or something. I'm going to get set up by people I respect. Exactly. Exactly. Exactly. So we want intent in that stage. And what that allows us to do is be mindful of our own time, not waste our own time, and actually honor our boundaries and honor what it is that we're looking for, our standards essentially in this stage. And once we meet somebody that we're interested in and we're looking in the right place and we have the intentions of what we're consciously looking for, the next big piece underneath that is you want to go in and be like, okay, I need to start asking the questions
所以，如果我们正确地进行了约会阶段，那就是关于了解契合度。这是为了有意识地观察是否存在实际的契合。所以我经常对人们说：写下你的标准，写下你的需求，然后去进行第一次约会，看看有没有化学反应，看看你们玩得是否开心，看看有没有连接。在那之后，你打算每次约会问一个难题。所以，我知道对我来说，作为一个例子——显然我和我丈夫已经结婚10年了，但如果我要进入约会场景，我会想，对我和我来说，首要事情之一就是我想知道某人是否能够处理冲突。我不喜欢把事情扫到地毯底下。我喜欢把事情摊开来解决。这对我极其重要。
that are going to get to the bottom of whether or not we're compatible. So if we're doing the dating stage right, it's about learning compatibility. It's about being intentional to see if there's actually a, fit. And so what I often say to people is like, write out your standards, write out your needs, and then go on your first date, just see if there's chemistry, see if you have a fun time, see if there's a connection. And after that, you want to intend to ask one hard question per date. So, you know, I know for me as an example, like obviously I've been married with my husband for 10 years, but if I were going into a dating scenario, I would be like, you know,
所以，你知道，我可能会在第一次约会时玩得很开心。在第二次约会时，我可能会问：“你是如何处理冲突的？我太好奇了。比如，如果你的生活中出现冲突，你通常会怎么做？”
for me, one of the first things would be I want to know that somebody can work through conference. I don't want to, I don't like to sweep things under the rug. I like to hash things up. That's extremely important to me. So, you know, I might go on the first date, have fun. And on a second date, I might say, how do you handle conflict? I'm so curious. Like, what do you tend to do if there's conflicts in your life?
我可能会问关于朋友或家人的事情。如果我听到有人说：“哦，我只是不喜欢冲突。我从来不和人冲突。我只是把事情忽略掉，然后搁在一边。我不喜欢进行那样的对话。”如果我想让事情变得简单，我可能会问：“好吧，如果这很重要，你愿意去解决它吗？”
I might ask about like with friends or family. If I hear somebody say, oh, I just don't like conflict. I never have it. I just kind of ignore stuff. And, you know, park it away. I don't like to have conversations like that. I'm looking for things to be easy. I might be like, well, would you be willing to address things if it was important to
如果他们回答：“啊，我觉得不会。”我可能就不会再安排第二次约会了，因为这是我的底线。所以你可以通过这些难题触及核心。这也引发了有趣且有意义的对话。而这正是约会阶段的全部意义所在：去了解这个人，看看他们是否真的能够融入你的生活。另一方面，很多人也容易走入的误区是，我们在约会阶段也同样需要展现真实的自我。我们也必须让自己接受别人的甄别。所以当我们进行这些对话时，我们也必须对其他人真诚、诚实地分享自己，因为我们必须让他们看看我们是否也是适合他们的人。我认为太多人，
you. And if they were like, ah, and I'll touch you, I probably wouldn't go on another date because that's a non-negotiable for me. And so you get to get to the bottom of these hard questions. And it also draws out interesting and meaningful conversation. And that's the whole point of the dating stage is to get to know the person and see if they're actually going to fit into your life. And on the flip side, where a lot of people also tend to miss the mark is that we also owe our own authenticity in the dating stage. And we have to let ourselves get vetted too. So when we have these conversations, we also have to share ourselves truthfully and honestly with other people because we have to let them see if they're, you know, we're a good fit for them as well. And I think too many people,
他们有点讨好别人，试图说所有正确的话，而不是真实的话。你会发现，尽管这在短期内可能看起来更轻松、更能满足自我，但从长远来看，对一段关系成功的几率实际上更糟糕，因为如果在约会阶段我们过于讨好，并且过度假装我们对某些事情没意见，而实际上我们有意见；或者我们假装自己没有实际上对我们意义重大的界限或需求，那么当你进入权力之争阶段时，自然会有各种问题浮出水面，我们在那里展露真实的自我，那时你们成功度过后续阶段的可能性就会大大降低。为了取得长远的成功，你要正确地进行甄别，
they kind of people please and try to say all the right things instead of the authentic things. And what you'll find is even though that might seem easier and more gratifying in the short term, it's actually much worse for the long-term relationships chance of success because if we're people pleasing too much in the dating stage and pretending too much that we're okay with things we aren't and we don't have boundaries that we actually do or we don't have needs that they're actually really meaningful to us by the time you get to the power struggle stage where naturally things start to come out of the woodworks and we show our truth there you are so much less likely to make it through so to successfully the later stages you set yourself up for success you vet
恰当地甄别，展现真实的自我，真诚地分享自己。在进入恋爱关系之前，我们就清楚自己的标准和底线，并试着在正确的地方寻找。这些就是重大的“成人礼”。而且这能阻止自己受到伤害。你知道我的意思吗？在这个阶段，你可能还没有与某人建立深厚的情感羁绊，或者根本没有羁绊。比如，你可能会和一个你真正喜欢并爱上的人进入权力之争阶段，因为，你知道的，你花时间陪伴了他们，然而他们仍然是你们刚见面时那个原本的人，如果你能早点意识到：我们永远不可能合拍。那么，你就能为自己省去多少痛苦啊。我还想问你关于
properly, you show up with your authentic self, you share yourself authentically. We know our standards and non-negotiables going into the relationship and we try to look in the right places. And those are like the big key rights of passage. And you stop yourself from being hurt. You know what I mean? Like at this stage, you probably aren't deeply emotionally bonded to someone or bonded at all. Like, you know, you could get to the like the power struggle phase with somebody and really like them and love them because, like, you spent time with them, whereas they're still the same person that they were when you first met them, like, if you were able to realize, like, we are never going to be compatible early on. Like, you save yourself so much pain. I also want to ask you about
这个的问题，我知道现在有很多人都在问自己：在这个阶段，我如何才能不被某人的理想化版本冲昏头脑？那个我自己说服自己可能会实现的版本，特别是关于承诺。你知道，有人会说：“哦，是的，我真的想慢慢来。我其实不求认真的关系，但让我们看看事情会怎么发展。”而在你的脑海里，你听到的是：“哦，我只需要赢得他们的芳心。或者他们只是需要时间。”或者你开始听到你想听的话。
this, which is something that I know so many people are going to be asking themselves right now, how do I not just get carried away with the idealized version of someone during this stage? the version that I convinced myself could happen, especially I think around commitment. You know, someone says like, oh yeah, I just really want to take things slow. I'm not really looking for anything serious, but let's see where things go. And in your mind, you hear, oh, I just need to win them over. Or they just need time. Or you start hearing things that you want to hear.
在这个阶段，你该如何应对内心深处可能存在的这种倾向？我喜欢这个问题。这是一个非常棒的问题。当然，你总是能提出很棒的问题。我要说的第一件事是，我们要设定一个目标和意图：不去和人的“潜力”约会。当我以前还在经营我的诊所时，我有一些客户——
How do you deal with that maybe tendency within you during this stage? I love that question. That was a phenomenal question. Of course, you always ask great questions. The first thing I would say is that we want to set a goal and an intention to not date people's potential. And when I would have clients, you know, back in the day when I was running my practice, I would get them, people who I would say are, you know, predisposed to doing that.
你知道的，那些容易陷入这种倾向的人。你知道的，那些稍微有些焦虑的人，他们总能看到别人最好的一面。这真是一个迷人的品质，但他们更有可能这样做。我实际上会让他们写一本约会日记。我会让他们——事实上我会告诉大家，这也是一个在家可以做的极好练习——在约会之后、在与某人共度时光之后，我会问他们，我会让他们回答：这个人实际上是怎样让我有感觉的？
You know, the types of people who are a little more anxious, they see the best in people. It's such a charming quality, but they're much more likely to do that. I would actually get them to keep a dating journal. and I would get them to, and I would actually tell people, and this is a great exercise to do at home, is I would get them to after a date, after spending time with somebody, I would ask them, I would get them to say, how is this person actually making me feel? Okay. Because sometimes that question, when we're so into the fantasy, and then we don't hear from them and we're anxious or they're not great at communicating or the date's not going that well, sometimes we cope by
因为有时候当我们在幻想中，而当我们联系不到他们或者我们感到焦虑，或者他们的沟通能力不太好，或者约会进行得不那么顺利时，我们有时会通过陷入幻想来应对，而实际上我们已经脱离了现实。当我们脱离现实并在幻想中运作时，我们就不在自己的身体里了。我们实际上不在体内。我们稍微有些解离。我们的意识和幻想停留在这里，而我们却忘了去亲身感受现实中正在发生的事情。所以，“这个人实际上是怎样让我有感觉的？”这是一个很好的问题，可以让你脚踏实地，让你重新扎根于你的身体，我曾无数次看到人们处于
getting into the fantasy and we actually leave the reality. And when we leave reality and operate in the fantasy, we're out of our body. We're actually not in our body. We're slightly dissociated. We're up here in our mind and our fantasy and we forget to feel in our body what's actually happening. And so, hey, how is this person actually making me feel is a really good place to ground you, anchor you back in your body, the amount of times I would see people in very intermittent
时断时续的关系中，或者对方没有表现出来而他们在追逐的关系中？然后你问：“好吧，这个人实际上是怎样让我有感觉的？”他们会说：“哦，其实我一直都很焦虑。其实我跟这个人约会时晚上都很难入睡。天哪，你知道的。”所以它真的能让你脚踏实地。这是一个非常值得问自己的问题。然后我让人们进行打分。你知道的，你去追踪你的标准，追踪你的需求。当你在甄别他们时，你就在为此写日记。他们真的做到了吗？如果你发现：“哦，他们可能会，或者以后也许会”——当你把这些事情写进日记时，我们必须不断回到现实中。
relationships or relationships where people weren't showing up and they're chasing? And then you say, well, how is this person actually making you feel? And they're like, oh, I'm actually anxious all the time. I'm actually like having a hard time sleeping at nights and dating this person. Oh my God, you know. So it really anchors you. It's a really good question to ask yourself. And then I get people to rate. You know, you go in, you track your standards, you track your needs. And as you're vetting them, you're journaling about it. Are they actually showing up for this? And if you're seeing, oh, they could or maybe they will in the future as you're journaling these things out, we have to keep coming back to the reality.
他们真的做到了吗？他们在做这些事情吗？因为当我们——你知道的，无论什么时候我们甄别某人时，我们绝对、毫无疑问地必须甄别他们的行为，而不是他们的言语。这就是正确甄别的诀窍。如果我们甄别他们的行为，那就是他们真正在做的事情。这很有趣，因为你的行为就是真正的你。你的行为是你潜意识习惯化的模式，而潜意识构成了你所有的信念、想法、情绪和行动的95%以上。所以，当你从行为的角度出发时，“这个人发短信的方式很连贯。很好。这就是他们的表现。”“哦，这个人情感成熟，
Are they? Are they doing these things now? Because when we, you know, whenever we're vetting somebody, we absolutely unequivocal, have to be vetting their behavior, not their words. And that is the trick to veting properly. If we vet their behavior, it's what they're already doing. And it's interesting because your behavior is who you actually are. Your behavior is your subconscious habituated patterns and your subconscious makes up 95 plus percent of all of your beliefs and thoughts and emotions and actions. And so when you're moving from a place of behavior, oh, this person is being consistent in how they text. Good. This is how they're showing up. Oh, this person is emotionally available. and really listing and being present on dates. Okay, great. This is how they're showing up.
在约会时真正倾听并保持专注。好的，太棒了。这就是他们的表现。”相比之下，如果只看我们的愿望或我们在他们的言语中希望看到的东西。我说：“哦，是的，我会努力多给你发短信的。没问题。”但他们并没有。好吧，那属于他们的愿望或言语。这不在他们的行为中。所以当我们进行甄别时，这是让我们保持扎根于真理和现实的最佳方法之一，这样我们才不会被幻想冲昏头脑。最后我要补充的一点是——这也是一个很好的问题——如果你发现自己正是那种容易被冲昏头脑、渴望被选择、想要赢得对方芳心并把这放在首位的人，我们也必须扪心自问：我体内的什么东西在那种状态下感觉如此安全和舒适？为什么我总是不断迷失自我、追逐、渴望被选择，并将“被选择的需求”置于我的真实感受以及我的需求是否真正得到满足之上？有时候是因为我们有一个让我们有这种感受的童年。有时候是因为那是我们熟悉和舒适的东西，因此觉得安全。或者有时候是因为，你知道的，我们只是陷入了“害怕自己不够好”的巨大心理创伤中。如果我们看到这些重大的东西浮现出来，那么这就是深入探究它们的绝佳时机。也许可以围绕这些核心信念做一些神经重塑或疗愈，这样我们就能让自己从不断重复这些模式中解放出来。说真的，太棒了，简直是一针见血的建议。作为一个曾经确实倾向于寻求被选择，然后改变了自己应对这些情况方式的人，
Versus in my desires or what I would hope to see in their words. I say, oh, yeah, I'll try to text you more often. No problem. But they don't. Right. Well, then that's in their desires or their words. It's not in their behavior. So when we're vetting, that's one of the best things to really keep us anchored in the truth and in the reality so we don't get carried away from the fantasy. And just the last thing I would say to that, too, is like such a good question is if you find yourself being the person who has the tendency to get carried away and want to be chosen and want to win the person over and you're prioritizing that, we also have to ask ourselves, what in me feel so safe and comfortable in that? Why do I keep leaving myself and chasing and wanting to be
这真的管用。它绝对管用。完全正确。好了。所以我们甄别得很棒。我们完成了工作。我们非常擅长获取别人的推荐人、了解别人的性格特征、理解别人的核心动机和他们是谁。要进入热恋阶段需要什么？这个阶段感觉如何？它与前后的阶段有什么不同？是的，问得好。
chosen and prioritizing the need to be chosen over how I'm actually feeling, how much my needs are actually met? And sometimes it's because we had a childhood where we felt like that. Sometimes it's because that's what's familiar and comfortable for us and thus safe. Or sometimes it's because, you know, we're just caught in this huge wound of fearing not being good enough. And if we see those big things popping out, then it's a really good time to dig into those things. Maybe do some rewiring or some healing around those core beliefs so that we can free ourselves from continuously enacting those patterns. Honestly, amazing, spot on advice. As someone who definitely used to have a tendency to be chosen and then change the way I approached those situations,
所以从约会阶段过渡出来——
it works. It definitely does. Exactly. Okay. So we've vetted well. We've done our job. We've been very good at getting people's references, getting people's character references, understanding people's like cool motivations and who they are. What does it take to move into the honeymoon stage? And what does this stage feel like and how does it feel differently to the stages before and after? Yeah, great question.
而且我认为这非常重要，就像真正做好甄别一样。我也想说一件事，因为有时我注意到人们会觉得：“哦，这就像是一场求职面试。”你可不希望约会变成一场求职面试。那不是最终目标。所以你要确保——这就是为什么我总是说“每次约会问一个问题”，因为这样你就可以玩得开心、保持当下、做你自己，但你
So coming out of the dating stage, And I think it's so important to like that really properly. I also want to say one thing too because sometimes I notice people will be like, oh, it's like a job interview. Like you don't want dating to be a job interview. That's not the goal. So you want to make sure that you're, that's why I always say like ask one question per date because then you can have fun and be present and do your thing, but you're
在不断取得进展。你一直在了解一点重要的信息。所以通常情况下，当我们觉得自己已经很好地掌握了这一点。一旦你觉得对方也对你有了很好的把握，当你进入热恋阶段时，你会看到它的标志是花更多的时间和某人在一起。通常在这个时候我们会相当稳定地与他们交流，几乎每天或每一天。很多时候也是这样，你会每周花几个晚上和他们在一起。你们把很多时间花在一起。你可以看出，
constantly getting, you're moving the needle. You're constantly learning a little bit of the important information. So generally we, we tend to once we feel like we've got a really good grasp of that. And once we feel like the other person you can tell has the grasp of of you, what you'll start to see as you enter towards the honeymoon stage is it's marked by spending more time with somebody. Usually we're speaking to them quite consistently at this point, like almost every day or every day. A lot of times as well, it's like you'll spend a couple of nights a week with them. You're spending a lot of your time together. And you can tell, you know,
不断地获取，你在推动进展。你不断地学到一点点重要信息。所以通常我们，一旦我们觉得自己对这一点有了很好的掌握，一旦我们觉得对方——你能看出对方也——掌握了你所表达的，你开始看到的进入蜜月期的标志是，你会花更多的时间和某人在一起。通常在这个时候我们会相当持续地与他们交流，比如几乎每天或每天。很多时候，你也会每周花几个晚上和他们在一起。你们花很多时间在一起。你能感觉得到，你知道，
there's not really room for somebody to be doing this with multiple people in their lives or, you know, how would they hold down a job and date like this at the same time? You know, there's two, it's a lot of time commitment. And so once we see this progress towards that, usually around the three to four month mark is sort of the healthy space where you've had the chance to collect enough information, as soon as there is a commitment in a relationship. So, hey, we're going to be together. We're going to be exclusive. It's just going to be us dating each other. Once there's a conversation, that is the exact right of passage that moves you into the honeymoon stage. So once there's an actual conversation, we've decided to commit to each other, we're going to be with each other,
一个人在生活中真的很难同时跟多个人这样做，或者说，你知道的，他们怎么可能一边维持一份工作，一边这样约会呢？你知道的，有两件事，这需要投入大量的时间。所以，一旦我们看到朝着这个方向发展，通常在三到四个月左右，这是一个健康的阶段，在这个阶段里，你已经有机会收集足够的信息，只要一段关系中出现了承诺。所以，嘿，我们要在一起了。我们要确定独占关系。就是我们互相约会。一旦有了这种对话，这就是把你带入蜜月期的正确过渡仪式。所以一旦有了真正的对话，我们决定向彼此承诺，我们要和彼此在一起，
then there you are. You're in the honeymoon. stage. Now, some people do try to move there a little earlier. Some people do move there a little later. Um, but three to four months is usually the best zone. And for people, I find the most securely attached. People actually move from that space. And it's kind of a sweet spot. And the honeymoon stage then becomes, okay, you're officially in this relationship and we'll be a little more vulnerable with each other. We'll be a little more open with each other with our feelings, specifically expressing love, care, excitement, making longer term plans, like maybe to go on a trip or vacation. You know, there will be this sort of increase in.
那么，你就在那儿了。你就在蜜月期。现在，有些人确实会试图更早地进入这个阶段。有些人确实会晚一点进入。嗯，但三到四个通常是最好的阶段。而且对于那些依恋最安全的人，我发现他们实际上是从那个空间过渡过来的。而且这算是一个绝佳的平衡点。然后蜜月期就会变成，好吧，你们正式确立了这段关系，我们会向彼此展露更多脆弱的一面。我们会向彼此更多地敞开心扉，表达我们的感受，特别是表达爱、关心、兴奋，制定更长期的计划，比如可能去旅行或度假。你知道，会有这样一种增加……
Exactly, exactly. You know, there's this increase of bringing this person into your life, introducing them to your friends, sharing more of your internal world with them. And it's a really beautiful phase. And in this phase specifically, what's really interesting is you can see that people, they have elevated oxytocin in this stage, which is the bonding neurochemical. They have elevated dopamine, which is the motivation neurochemical. And what's interesting about this is, have you ever noticed how people in the honeymoon stage, you're always like motivated to go out with them and do things with them. Let's go to dinner. Let's go here. And you always want to talk about them constantly. You're always talking about them with your friends and family.
没错，没错。你知道，这种把这个人带进你的生活、把他们介绍给你的朋友、与他们分享更多你的内心世界的行为有所增加。这真是一个美好的阶段。而且在这个阶段，特别有趣的是，你可以看到人们在这个阶段会有升高的催产素，这是负责建立亲密关系的神经化学物质。他们有多巴胺的升高，这是负责激发出行动力的神经化学物质。关于这一点，有趣的是，你有没有发现，蜜月期的人总是很有动力和对方一起出去玩，和他们一起做事情？我们去吃晚饭吧。我们去这里吧。而且你总是想不停地谈论他们。你总是在朋友和家人面前谈论他们。
I have a friend who's in this stage right now. Love it a bit, but she came up for dinner last night. And I was like, I cannot, I can't hear about him anymore. I'm so sorry, but she's so obsessed. Yeah, exactly. And so we have all of this like neurochemical cocktail of things. We even have the phenylatholamine neurochemical, which is all about attraction. So we have all of this like bonding attraction motivation and you'll see it in people's behavior and it's a really beautiful stage and after the zero to six months so somewhere in that range of dating we then move into about a year to a year and a half of honeymoon and interestingly enough um this is often where a lot of people will will get engaged get married you know i've seen a lot yeah and jama the amount of
我有一个朋友现在就处于这个阶段。虽然有点受不了，但她昨晚来吃晚饭了。我当时就想，我不能，我真的不能再听她聊他了。真的很抱歉，但她实在是太着迷了。对，没错。所以我们拥有所有这些类似神经化学鸡尾酒的东西。我们甚至还有苯乙胺这种神经化学物质，它全关乎吸引力。所以我们拥有所有这些像亲密感、吸引力、动力这样的东西，你会在人们的行为中看到它，这真是一个美好的阶段。而在经历了最初的零到六个月之后——也就是约会的大致那个范围之后，我们随后会进入大约一年到一年半的蜜月期，有趣的是，嗯，这通常是很多人会订婚、结婚的阶段，你知道，我见过很多，是的，而且杰玛，那些……
people who i when i was back in the day when i was running my practice before i went into all the online space, I would have so many clients who would say, Taise, I married my wife. And then after two years, as soon as after we got married, she turned into a monster. Or I married. My husband, as soon as it got married, he turned into someone he never was. And people would get confused because, honestly, a lot of people would think, I'd say like roughly 10% of people would get married in the honeymoon stage, then move into the power struggle stage after marriage and think that their spouse, like, tricked them into
当我还在经营我的诊所，在进入所有这些网络空间之前的那些日子里，有那么多客户会对我泰丝说，我娶了我的妻子。然后两年后，我们一结婚，她就变成了一个怪物。或者我嫁给了我的丈夫，一结婚，他就变成了他从不是的那种人。人们会感到困惑，因为老实说，很多人会认为，我可以说大约10%的人会在蜜月期结婚，然后在婚后进入权力争夺阶段，并认为他们的配偶好像是“骗”他们……
to marrying them or pretended to be someone that they weren't and that they were truly the secret like monster behind closed doors. And when people, when I would explain to people, no, no, no, no, you just, it's too early. You never made into the power struggle stage. This is natural. This is normal. You just have to learn to navigate these things that are coming up. The amount of relief people would have of like, oh, it's a stage.
跟他们结婚，或者假装成一个他们并不是的人，而关起门来，他们其实是一个秘密的“怪物”。而当人们……当我向人们解释时，不，不，不，不，你只是……时间太早了。你从来没有进入过权力争夺阶段。这是很自然的。这是正常的。你只需要学会应对这些浮现出来的事情。人们会感到多么如释重负啊，会觉得“哦，原来这只是一种阶段”。
It's not that I was tricked. You know, and a lot of people would feel almost a sense of betrayal when you move into the power struggle stage because, you know, you could date somebody, feel really good about them, get engaged at nine months or a year, get married, you know, half a year later and you're still in your honeymoon. So at this point of time, this is usually that next year to year and a half. And we'll actually, you know, it's a beautiful time. It's lots of fun, all these great things. But something else really important to note is that people are still moving from more conditionally based love because you haven't had to have the hard conversations show and
并不是我被骗了。你知道的，当你进入权力争夺阶段时，很多人几乎会感到一种背叛感，因为你知道，你可以和某人约会，对他们感觉很好，在九个月或一年时订婚，半年后结婚，而你其实还在蜜月期。所以在此时此刻，这通常就是接下来的这一年到一年半。而且实际上，你知道的，这是一段美好的时光，有很多乐趣，所有这些美妙的事情。但还有一件非常重要的事情需要注意，那就是人们仍然在从更多基于条件的爱过渡，因为你还没经历过需要进行艰难对话、展现并……
share a lot of your deep interferes and flaws the way that you will just mourn the power struggle struggle stage. And so you still have the mask on a little bit. You're still kind of a little on your best behavior, maybe kind of thinking about what you're going to really show or share with the person. And so once we start getting really comfortable and once we start letting down the mask and letting somebody in, when we get into that space of comfort, all of those neurochemicals actually reduce. Okay. So the phenylethylalanine and the oxytocin and the dopamine, we start getting more comfortable, we enter into the power struggle, and it's precisely this that actually triggers off the power struggle itself, because we'll start saying, hey, actually,
分享你许多内心深处的恐惧和缺点，就像你在权力争夺阶段所必须做的那样。所以你身上仍然带着一点面具。你仍然表现得有点像最好的自己，也许还在考虑你究竟要向对方展示什么或分享什么。所以一旦我们开始真正感到舒适，一旦我们开始放下面具并让某人走进来，当我们进入那种舒适的状态时，所有这些神经化学物质其实都会减少。好吧。所以苯乙胺、催产素和多巴胺，我们开始感到更舒适，我们进入了权力争夺，而恰恰是这一点，实际上引发了权力争夺本身，因为我们会开始说，嘿，其实……
that's not okay with me. Actually, that's a boundary for me. Actually, I know I said I like this, but I don't. As soon as people start sharing more of their deep inner world, it's a crisis for people, but it's also an opportunity. It's like there's this challenge because now we're seeing all these in-depth insights into somebody. And we have to figure out how to mesh them. And that can be really hard at first. But you're also getting this deep opportunity to see into somebody way more that you love and to let them into your world way more and to share your authenticity at a deeper level with them. So if we do the power struggle right, then things can be really beautiful. And a lot of, you know, richness in the relationship can come out of that. But really that marked right of passage
这对我来说是不行的。其实，这是我的底线。其实，我知道我说过我喜欢这个，但其实我并不喜欢。一旦人们开始分享更多他们内心深处的世界，对人们来说这是一场危机，但这也是一个机会。这就像是存在这样一个挑战，因为现在我们正在看到关于某人的所有深入洞察。而我们必须弄清楚如何将它们融合在一起。这在一开始可能会非常难。但你同时也获得了这个绝佳的机会，能够更深入地了解你所爱的人，让他们更多地走进你的世界，并在更深的层面上与他们分享你的真实自我。所以如果我们把权力争夺处理好，那么事情就会变得非常美好。而关系中的许多丰富性也能够从中产生。但真正标志性的过渡仪式……
from the honeymoon to the power struggle as you start getting more comfortable. And as soon as you get more comfortable, the mask drops more, and that will be what triggers off the power struggle stage. Okay, I'm so excited to ask you some follow-up questions because I have them, of course, but we are going to take a short break here. When we come back, we're going to talk more about the power struggle stage, rhythm stage, devotion stage. Stay with us. We'll be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness. I break down the science of mental toughness. fitness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers,
从蜜月期到权力争夺期，就是当你开始感到越来越舒适的时候。而一旦你感到更舒适，面具就会掉得更多，而这正是将触发权力争夺阶段的导火索。好吧，我太兴奋想问你一些后续问题了，因为我当然有这些问题，但我们要在这里做一个短暂的休息。当我们回来时，我们将更多地谈论权力争夺阶段、节奏阶段、奉献阶段。请继续收听。我们马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理坚韧性的科学。我将剖析心理坚韧性的科学……体能，健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、
researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 iHeartRadio 上的 TWO percent，苹果播客，或者任何你收听播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击莉儿·金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈 80 年代的快克（可卡因）。坦白说，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时都可以聊一聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以…… 谢谢你把这句话说完。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学理》（Learn the Hard Way），我是您的主持人，也是您最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是…… 蒂普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍然在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines,
因为你觉得当你在地球上时做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯的行列，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
在我的新播客《艰难学理》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant.
随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达多年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支由网络侦探组成的军队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never. Mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要…… 惹恼乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he
我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女朋友们》中…… 天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们把事情掌握在了自己手中。我当时说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的……
deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I kind of mentioned, me and my partner, have been together for almost three years. And we definitely hit the power struggle stage recently, right? We are in the process of moving overseas together and all these like big milestones happened. And there was definitely a part of me when this friction started emerging where I was like, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, like this, we've made like maybe this relationship isn't right or like maybe we don't, we're not compatible. Having like kind of now probably moved a little bit more over this hill, why do you think this
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。所以，我刚才提到过，我和我的伴侣已经在一起快三年了。我们最近确实进入了权力争夺阶段，对吧？我们正在一起经历搬到海外的过程，所有这些重大里程碑都发生了。当这种摩擦开始出现时，我心里确实有一部分会想，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，就像这样，我们已经……也许这段关系并不对劲，或者也许我们不……我们并不般配。现在大概已经有点翻过这座山了，你认为为什么……
stage has to happen? and why do you think a lot of people break up in this stage, whether rightly or wrongly? So, yeah, such a great question. So to your point, every single person pretty much across the boards, even securely attached people, they have moments of those thoughts in the power struggle stage. So I think that's one of the most important things to say is that like when you said, oh, is this right? Are we compatible?
这个阶段是必须要经历的？你认为为什么很多人在这个阶段分手，不论对错？所以，是的，这是一个非常好的问题。说到这一点，几乎所有的人，甚至包括依恋安全的人，在权力争夺阶段都会有这种想法的时刻。所以我认为最重要的事情之一就是，当你刚才说“哦，这是对的吗？我们般配吗？
Is this working? Like, that is so normal. And that's every person's experience. And it's because we have this friction in this stage. And so, you know, obviously there's a difference if somebody's like having these explosive arguments every day, all day and they're miserable and then they're asking those questions. But there is a natural, just like when we go through stages of life, sometimes we question
这行得通吗？”时，这太正常了。这是每个人的经历。这是因为我们在这一阶段存在摩擦。所以，你知道的，如果有人每天、整天都在进行这种爆发性的争论，痛苦不堪，然后他们还在问这些问题，那显然是有区别的。但就像我们经历生命的各个阶段一样，有时我们会质疑……
ourselves and different things. Oh, you know, maybe you start a new career. Wait, can I really do this? Am I on the right track? You know, there's these natural sort of insecurities that pop up when we have problems. And I find that to be one of the most relieving things for people to hear because you know, people would happen. One of the biggest reasons people break up in that stage is they take those thoughts so seriously.
我们自己以及各种事情。哦，你知道的，也许你开始了一份新工作。等等，我真的能胜任吗？我走对方向了吗？你知道的，当我们遇到问题时，这些自然的缺乏安全感的情绪就会冒出来。我发现这对人们来说是听到最宽慰的事情之一，因为你知道，人们会发生这种情况。人们在那个阶段分手的最大原因之一，就是他们把那些想法看得太严肃了。
And then they start catastrophizing and magnifying. And then they see everything through that lens. And they're like, see, oh my gosh, we're not compatible. I knew it. And then they like play into it more and more. And then the other person's doing the same thing. And then we have this vicious cycle that happens when in reality, I find that if people just knew that, hey, this stage is going to be a little bit confronting, you're going to have moments
然后他们开始灾难化和放大。接着他们通过那种镜头看待一切。然后他们就会说，看吧，哦，天哪，我们根本不般配。我就知道。然后他们就会更加深陷其中，而另一个人也在做同样的事情。于是我们就陷入了这样一个恶性循环，而实际上，我发现如果人们只要知道，“嘿，这个阶段会有点具有挑战性，你会有这些时刻……”
at times in the stage, especially when it's, starts off where there's doubts and you question the relationship, just like if you start a new career and it's a learning curve, you're going to be like, wait, am I good enough to do this? Like, we do that and it's human and it's so normal. So I just, that's a huge thing first. And then going into it, the stage is necessary because it is, I think it's such a beautiful stage. People don't like to hear that when they're in it. But yeah, I'm sure. whole stage because people get this opportunity to move the needle for more conditionally based love to more unconditionally based love. And so often people would say to me, oh, Taiz, what if I want to
在这个阶段的某些时候，尤其是当它刚开始、出现怀疑并且你开始质疑这段关系时，就像你开始一份新工作并且有一个学习曲线一样，你会觉得：等等，我真的足够优秀来做这件事吗？我们都会这样，这是人性的表现，也是非常正常的。所以我认为这首先是一个巨大的前提。然后深入来看，这个阶段是必要的，因为它是……我认为这是一个非常美好的阶段。人们在身处其中时并不喜欢听到这个说法。但是的，我确信。整个阶段，因为人们获得了这个机会，可以将指针从更多基于条件的爱转向更多基于无条件的爱。所以经常有人对我说，哦，泰丝，如果我想……
stay in the honeymoon stage forever? And I'm like, do you want to just conditionally love your partner forever? Like, is that what you? Because even though it's scary, you know, you get to see into this person. You get to like really learn about their fears and their flaws and their needs more deeply. And you'll have to learn to move out of the stage and move through the stage of how to navigate conflict, how to be vulnerable. One of the biggest reasons people break up to the second part of your question is that you actually will not be able to make it out of the stage unless you learn vulnerability. And I remember when I joined you on an episode a while back and you shared it on the episode, it was such a touching way you shared it. And you talked about
永远留在蜜月期呢？而我会说：难道你想永远无条件地爱你的伴侣吗？这真的是你想要的吗？因为尽管这很可怕，你知道的，你得以深入了解这个人。你得以真正了解他们的恐惧、缺点和需求，并更深入地了解它们。你将不得不学会如何走出这个阶段，经历这个阶段，学习如何应对冲突，如何变得脆弱。导致人们分手的第二个原因，也是你问题的第二部分，就是如果你不学会展现脆弱，你实际上将无法度过这个阶段。我记得之前我加入你的节目时，你在节目中分享过这件事，你分享它的方式太触动人心了。你谈到了……
like sort of being vulnerable and sharing something that was vulnerable for you and it going well and just having this sort of like, wow, like moment of receiving that. And you can think back, you know, for anybody who's ever been through that, the moment before you're vulnerable for the first time with somebody in a pretty meaningful way, it's terrifying. It's so scary. But the moment when you've had the conversation that goes well, it's a huge breakthrough. And once you do that once and then twice and then a few more times and now you're both doing it with each other, you're literally building such deep roots for your tree. Like you're truly getting into a space where like the roots are building and they're growing and they're becoming, they're making the tree so much more unshakable. And so, you know,
比如展现脆弱，分享一些对你来说很脆弱的事情，结果进展得很顺利，并且有了一种类似“哇”的、接受这一切的时刻。你可以回想一下，你知道的，对于任何经历过这一切的人来说，在第一次与某人在一个相当有意义的层面展现脆弱之前的那个时刻，它是令人恐慌的。它是如此可怕。但当你进行了那次进展顺利的对话的那个瞬间，这是一个巨大的突破。一旦你这样做了一次，然后两次，然后更多次，现在你们都在互相这样做，你实际上是在为你们的大树建造如此深厚的根基。就像你真的进入了一个这样的空间：根基正在建立，正在生长，并且它们正在变得……它们让这棵大树变得更加不可动摇。所以，你知道的……
once you get into that space, it's, yes, a crisis because there's hard things that will come up. And it's marked by, you know, statistically people will argue more at the beginning. You'll see if you can almost graph relationships. You go dating, honeymoon, there's this peak of infatuation power struggle. It's like all this fighting. And then the conflict goes way down. And the whole point of the power struggle, and there's really like four major rights of passage. Like we have to get these four things right or we'll stay stuck in the power struggle forever or the relationship will end within it.
一旦你进入那个空间，是的，这是一场危机，因为会有艰难的事情出现。它的标志是，从统计学上讲，人们在刚开始时会争吵得更多。如果你画出亲密关系的关系图，你会看到：约会、蜜月期，然后是迷恋的顶峰——权力争夺。这就好比所有的这些争吵。然后冲突就会大幅下降。而权力争夺的全部意义在于，这里面其实有四个主要的过渡仪式。就像我们必须把这四件事做好，否则我们将永远困在权力争夺中，或者关系会在其中结束。
Number one is vulnerability. Okay, so learning to actually share your inner world vulnerably. I'll tell a story here for a second. I had this client once and she was like this lovely, amazing, just beautiful human being. Had like all these great qualities, put a lot of pressure on herself to be perfect in every way, like so put together, so precise about everything. He had a great job, everything on paper. And she never ever could make it out of the power struggle stage with people. And she just wanted a loving long-term relationship.
第一点是脆弱性。好吧，所以要学会以脆弱的方式真实地分享你的内心世界。这里我讲一个小故事。我曾经有一个客户，她是一个可爱、令人惊叹、非常美好的人。拥有所有这些优秀的品质，给自己施加了很大的压力，要在方方面面都做到完美，就像那种把一切都打理得井井有条、对任何事都极其精确的人。她有一份很好的工作，纸面上的一切都无可挑剔。但她从来都无法和别人一起度过权力争夺阶段。她只想要一段充满爱意的长期关系。
But when we looked into her childhood, what we found is that she had a father who was quite narcissistic and always made her feel like second-guessing herself and she had to be perfect to get love from him and all these things. So she never would let somebody see her in her imperfections. And when people would break up with her in relationships, the common theme is people would say, I feel like I still don't know who you are. And I feel like we're like not getting anywhere. Yeah.
但当我们审视她的童年时，我们发现她有一个相当自恋的父亲，总是让她不断自我怀疑，她必须表现得完美才能从他那里得到爱，诸如此类的事情。所以她从来不让任何人看到她不完美的一面。而在恋爱关系中，当人们与她分手时，一个共同的主题就是人们会说：“我觉得我依然不了解你。而且我觉得我们的关系毫无进展。”是的。
And it's truly, no matter. or how quote unquote perfect somebody is or how well they have their life together or how, you know, you name it. If we can't get vulnerable, vulnerability is exactly what moves us from infatuation to real love. Yeah. And you could make a pretty strong argument that even though we can love in the dating and
这真的是这样，无论……一个人所谓的“完美”程度如何，无论他们的生活打理得多么井井有条，无论他们的……你随便说。如果我们无法展露脆弱，脆弱正是将我们从迷恋带向真爱的关键所在。是的。你可以提出一个非常有力的论据，那就是尽管我们在约会和……
honeymoon stage, it's still kind of an infatuation based love. It's still rooted in infatuation. And, you know, when we move into like the power struggle and we really deeply let somebody in and really let ourselves be seen and really learn about what each other's sensitivities are and fears, that vulnerability breeds much more unconditionally based love.
蜜月期可以感受到爱，但它仍然是一种基于迷恋的爱。它依然扎根于迷恋之中。而且，你知道的，当我们进入权力争夺阶段，真正深深地让一个人走进来，真正让自己被看见，并真正了解彼此的敏感点和恐惧是什么时，这种脆弱感会孕育出更多基于无条件的爱。
And we get this opening into that. And so vulnerability is this huge right of passage. And vulnerability then goes with us deeply learning how to meet each other's needs. Number two. And number three is like really learning how to navigate conflict around each other's fears and needs together. And so as an example, you know, you can think, let's say there's a couple. And let's say one person in the couple is somebody who needs a lot of presence. They want somebody to be attuned to them and be present with them and they really value like depth of emotional connection. And let's say we have another person in the couple who, you know, maybe that's a big need for the one person. And maybe the other person, they really need gentle communication when they're getting feedback.
我们得以打开通往这种爱的大门。因此，脆弱性是一个巨大的过渡仪式。而脆弱性随后伴随着我们，让我们深入学习如何满足彼此的需求。第二点。第三点是真正学会围绕彼此的恐惧和需求来共同应对冲突。举个例子，你知道的，你可以想象，假设有一对情侣。假设这对情侣中的一个人，是一个非常需要陪伴的人。他们希望有人能够关注他们并陪伴在他们身边，并且他们非常珍视情感连接的深度。假设我们还有另一个人，你知道的，也许这对那个人来说是一个巨大的需求。而也许另一个人，他们真的很需要温和的沟通，当他们得到反馈时。
Maybe they are a little sensitive to criticism and they don't take criticism or feedback that well. They kind of, you know, it wounds them a little bit and they're sensitive to it. So, you know, in this particular case, those could be issues where if one person, person's not that present and one person is a little more harsh or critical with their words, if somebody doesn't know there's a power struggle stage and know how to navigate it, then they could break up. But instead, if we have the ability to talk about these things and the person who's sensitive to feedback might say, hey, I want to try to hear feedback from you, but can you be a little more gentle in your delivery? Because, you know, it's a little hard for me sometimes. And
也许他们对批评有点敏感，他们不太能很好地接受批评或反馈。他们有点……你知道的，这会稍微伤害到他们，他们对这一点很敏感。所以，你知道的，在特定情况下，如果一个人不够专注，而另一个人在言语上稍微严厉或挑剔一些，如果有人不知道存在权力争夺阶段并且不知道如何应对它，那么他们可能会分手。但相反，如果我们有能力谈论这些事情，对反馈敏感的那个人可能会说：“嘿，我想试着听取你的意见，但你能说得稍微温和一点吗？因为，你知道的，这对有时我来说有点难。”而且……
it takes a certain degree of vulnerability to say that. But then if the other person is willing to do that work and meet them on that and practice that. And then if the person who, you know, say the other half of the couple is going, and okay, I'll work with my delivery. I'll be a little more gentle and considerate for sure. And also, I need you to be a little more present sometimes. You know, somebody being present and, you know, really listening is really important to me. And the other person is, okay, and I'll work on that too. We're not going to be perfect at it all of a sudden. You know, it takes a little bit of time to practice and work these things through. but once they actually meet in this in a middle ground, that's precisely when it's like,
说出这句话需要一定程度的脆弱性。但随后，如果另一个人愿意付出努力并在这一点上迎合他们并加以练习。然后，如果那个人，你知道的，假设情侣的另一半说：“好的，我会调整我的表达方式。我一定会更加温和和体贴。同时，我需要你有时能更多地陪伴我。你知道的，有人陪伴并且真正倾听对我很重要。”而另一个人说：“好的，我也会在这方面努力。我们不可能一下子就做到完美。你知道的，这需要一点时间去练习并解决这些事情。”但一旦他们真正找到了一个中间地带，那正是……
okay, now we're building really powerful routes. Now we know how to naturally take each other into consideration because we were vulnerable about these things. We heard each other's fears or flaws or sensitivities. We heard each other's needs. And now that equips us to properly navigate conflict. And so when conflict comes up, if we can approach conflict with vulnerability, with openness, with acceptance in this particular case,
“好的，现在我们正在建立非常强大的根基。现在我们知道如何自然地为对方着想，因为我们曾就这些事情展露过脆弱。我们听到了彼此的恐惧、缺点或敏感点。我们听到了彼此的需求。而现在这赋予了我们正确应对冲突的能力。”因此，当冲突出现时，如果我们能够以脆弱、开放、接纳的态度来处理冲突，在特定这种情况下，
all of these things start feeding together into us building healthier collective patterns where we may have to make slight compromises on each side. But what's so interesting here is a lot of people in the power struggle stage will say, yeah, I have to learn to navigate conflict a little bit more in the power struggle stage. I have to, why do we have to hash everything out
所有这些事情开始汇聚在一起，帮助我们建立更健康的集体模式，在这个模式中，我们可能不得不在双方做出轻微的妥协。但这里非常有趣的一点是，许多处于权力争夺阶段的人会说：“是的，我必须在权力争夺阶段学会更多地应对冲突。我必须……为什么我们必须把所有事情都争论清楚，
or talk about everything? It's only for a period of time. You'll have more conversations and more arguments because you're refusing your inner world. You have to talk about all these things that you don't know about each other yet. But once you naturally, okay, so let's pretend it's me and my husband and let's say I'm the person who wants more presence and maybe he's the person who wants conflict, you know,
或者讨论所有事情呢？”这只是一个时期而已。你会有更多的对话和更多的争吵，因为你在重新整理你的内心世界。你必须谈论所有这些你们还不了解对方的事情。但一旦你们自然而然地……好吧，让我们假装这是我和我的丈夫，假设我是那个想要更多陪伴的人，而也许他是那个想要冲突、你知道的……
kinder criticism and better delivery, if we start doing those things and we practice them together and we get better at them and I naturally am more mindful in my delivery, he naturally makes an effort to, you know, put his phone away and be more present when we spend time together, then when we fuse into that together, it's exactly. the fusing, and that's that fourth part, that moves us out of the power struggle and into the rhythm, because now we're in the rhythm. We're in the flow of doing these things. We worked on them together. We both made compromises. And by the way, usually the exact compromises that we'll make actually grow both of us and bring us closer together. And now in doing that, you get into
更温和的批评和更好的表达方式的人，如果我们开始做这些事情，并且我们一起练习它们，并且我们在这方面变得更好，我自然会在表达时更加用心，他自然会努力……你知道的，把手机收起来，在我们一起度过时光时更多地陪伴在身边，那么当我们把这些融合在一起时，这正是……这种融合，这就是第四部分，它让我们走出了权力争夺，进入了节奏阶段，因为现在我们处于节奏中了。我们处于做这些事情的流动状态中。我们一起努力解决了它们。我们都做出了妥协。顺便说一句，通常我们做出的确切妥协，实际上会让我们双方都得到成长，并将我们拉得更近。现在通过这样做，你进入了……
this rhythm. You don't have to talk about all these things so much. You know how, you know, naturally how to, let's pretend it's me and my husband. I naturally know to be kind in my delivery with my husband. I naturally have practiced that. It gets wired in. And now it's just something I do. And that's exactly and precisely when we start exiting the power struggle stage. It's the right of passage of when we've hashed out the important things enough. And we actually built in these new habits in the relationship where all of a sudden we consider each other without having to think it through or argue about it or talk about it. And then we feel more loved as we each need to feel loved in a relationship. And now we're in the rhythm of things. And that's what takes us out of that stage and
这种节奏。你不需要花那么多时间去谈论所有这些事情。你知道如何……你知道，自然而然地……让我们假装这是我和我的丈夫。我自然知道在与我丈夫交流时要语气温和。我自然已经练习过这一点。它已经被写入了我的潜意识。现在这成了我自然而然会做的事情。而这恰恰、正是我们开始走出了权力争夺阶段的时候。这是当我们把重要的事情讨论得足够充分时的过渡仪式。而且我们实际上在关系中建立起了这些新的习惯，以至于突然之间，我们开始为对方着想，而不需要深思熟虑、争吵或讨论它。然后我们感觉被更多地爱着，正如我们在恋爱关系中需要被爱的那样。现在我们处于事情的节奏中了。这就是把我们带出那个阶段、
to the next one. Which all sounds honestly very positive to me. And something I will say is you will be surprised how every single long-term couple relationship that you know has gone through this stage. Like every single one. I've been talking to my friends so much about it and they're like, oh yeah. Like, of course. We had that. Of course. And the love that you start to feel for your partner is honestly bigger than the honeymoon stage will ever be. Like, the honeymoon stage to me and how I imagine it is like eating a big ball of candy and like sweets and like maltisers and popcorn. It's like so delicious, right?
进入下一个阶段的东西。老实说，这一切听起来对我都非常积极。我要说的一点是，你会惊讶地发现，你所知道的每一对长期伴侣关系都经历过这个阶段。就像每一对都是如此。我一直在和我的朋友们大量谈论这件事，他们会说：“哦，是的。就像，当然。我们也有过。当然。”而你开始对伴侣感受到的爱，老实说，要比蜜月期所能感受到的任何爱都要伟大。就像在我看来蜜月期是怎么样的呢，就像吃一大球糖果、甜食、麦提莎巧克力和爆米花。它是如此美味，对吧？
And you just want to eat and eat and eat. And then like when you move, I'm guessing now we're going to go into the rhythm stage, into the stage. It's like having like an incredibly nourishing home cooked meal. Yeah, it might not like taste as like electric as a bowl of like literal gummy bears, but like it's so much better for you. And it does actually taste better as well. Let's talk about the rhythm stage. You've explained how we get to this stage by moving through conflict, being vulnerable, all those other rights of passage. What does it feel like in this moment? Yeah, I love your analogy so much. I've often said it's sort of like the pleasure seeking versus the fulfillment. Oh, I love that. Yeah, we get this like, ooh, like exciting. But like fulfillment can always outgrow pleasure seeking.
你只想一直吃、一直吃、一直吃。然后就像当你过渡到……我猜现在我们要进入节奏阶段，进入那个阶段。这就好像吃了一顿极其滋养的、家常做热腾腾的饭菜。是的，它可能不像一碗真正的软糖那样尝起来那么有电击般的刺激感，但它对你健康得多。而且实际上它的味道也更好。让我们来谈谈节奏阶段。你已经解释了我们如何通过经历冲突、展现脆弱以及所有这些其他的过渡仪式来达到这个阶段。此时此刻感觉如何？是的，我太喜欢你的这个比喻了。我经常说，这有点像追求快乐与获得成就感之间的区别。哦，我太喜欢这个了。是的，我们得到了这种……哦，像这样兴奋的感觉。但成就感总是能超越追求快乐。
You know, like fulfilling grows and grows and grows and there's a depth to it. And pleasure always hits like a glass ceiling. Like, oh, okay, cool, this is exciting. But you can only really get so far. But the depth of like love and care that you can feel somebody for somebody when you know them so well and you've talked things out and you let them see you so deeply and you feel seen and known and understood. like it's just such a totally different experience.
你知道的，比如成就感会不断增长、增长、再增长，其中包含着一种深度。而追求快乐总是会触及一个玻璃天花板。就像：哦，好吧，酷，这很让人兴奋。但你其实也只能走到这一步。然而，当你非常了解一个人，把事情都谈开，让他们深刻地看到你，并且你感到被看见、被了解和被理解时，你对一个人能感受到的那种爱与关怀的深度……就像这完全是另一种体验。
I love that analogy, the candy versus the home cooked meal, which is more nourishing and better for you. And yeah, that's fantastic. So once we get into the rhythm stage, I think you described it so beautifully. It's like you'll feel this depth of love
我太喜欢那个比喻了，糖果与家常饭菜的比喻，后者更具滋养性，对你更好。是的，这太棒了。所以一旦我们进入了节奏阶段，我想你把它描述得太美妙了。这就好像你会感受到这种爱的深度，
and you'll feel nourished by the relationship in a really profound way. And you'll know that there's a sense of comfort there, this sense of peace, the sense of being able to rely on this person. You'll feel like that person really knows you and you've let them in. And, you know, so many people, they get stuck.
并且你会以一种非常深刻的方式从这段关系中获得滋养。你会知道那里有一种安全感，一种平静感，一种能够依靠这个人的感觉。你会觉得那个人真的很了解你，而你也让他们走进了你的内心。而且，你知道的，很多人，他们被困住了。
And I know I mentioned this at a high level earlier, but like so many people get stuck in the power struggle stage. And then they, they don't get the opportunity to think that relationships are more than just the highs and lows. And that's another really important thing, you know, for people to hear, I find is that, hey, just because you're going through a hard time doesn't mean that that's like the cap of the relationship. Once you can learn communication and vulnerability and these practices, all of a sudden the needle moves. Like all of a sudden things change. And you get to enrich. It's almost like you level up in a really big way. And so in the rhythm stage, one of the first things that happens is like you catch your breath, quite honestly. Like there's a settling in. There's a fulfillment. There's a contentment because you're kind of coming from like high high of dating
我知道我之前在高层次上提到过这一点，但很多人被困在权力争夺阶段。然后他们……他们没有机会去思考，恋爱关系不仅仅是高潮和低谷。这也是人们需要听到的另一个非常重要的观点，我发现是这样的：“嘿，仅仅因为你正在经历一段艰难时期，并不意味着那就是这段关系的上限。”一旦你学会了沟通、脆弱以及这些实践，指针突然就会移动。就像突然之间事情变了。你得到了丰富。这几乎就像你在很大程度上升级了。所以在节奏阶段，发生的第一件事之一就是：坦白说，你会喘口气。就像有一种安定下来。有一种满足感。有一种知足感，因为跟……相比，你有点像是从约会的高潮……
and honeymoon and then low low of the power of struggle by comparison. And then it's like, oh my gosh, we get to this middle ground, this harmonious space, this space where we're not having conflict. we almost like preemptively avoid conflict by just looking out for each other. And this is the place too. And I think this is another really important thing. You know, when I was when I was a kid and I don't know if you've had this experience, but when I was a kid, I remember being like a teenager and dating somebody and maybe even being in like a pretty serious relationship at like 18 and thinking, how could this possibly,
和蜜月期走出来了，然后经历了权力争夺的低谷。然后就变成了：哦，天哪，我们来到了这个中间地带，这个和谐的空间，一个我们不再发生冲突的空间。我们几乎通过照顾彼此来先发制人地避免冲突。这也是一个地方。我认为这也是另一个非常重要的事情。你知道的，自我还是个孩子的时候——我不知道你是否有过这种经历，但自我还是个孩子的时候，我记得自己曾是个青少年，和某人约会，甚至可能在18岁时就处在一段相当认真的关系中，并且心想：这怎么可能……
like how could this possibly last forever? Like how do I possibly know I won't get bored in 10 years or they won't get bored? like sure, I like them now and like we're all great now, but like inevitably, things have to fall apart. Like, how could you know you're not going to change your mind? And I remember really grappling with that a lot when I was younger and thinking like, how would you know? But it's because I'd never been out of a power struggle stage or in anything beyond the power struggle. And one of the things that happens when you leave the power struggle and you get into the rhythm is it's like you've just nurtured something. You've just like cared so much for something. You've just cared for this relationship.
这怎么可能永远持续下去？就像我怎么可能知道我10年后不会觉得无聊，或者他们不会觉得无聊呢？就像，当然，我现在喜欢他们，而且我们现在都很好，但不可避免地，事情一定会分崩离析。就像，你怎么能知道你不会改变主意呢？我记得年轻时为此纠结了很久，心想：你怎么会知道呢？但那是因为我从未走出过权力争夺阶段，也从未体验过权力争夺之外的任何东西。当你离开权力争夺并进入节奏时，发生的事情之一就是：这就好像你刚刚精心呵护了某样东西。你刚刚对某样东西付出了那么多的关爱。你刚刚悉心照料了这段关系。
and you've been cared for, and you've like developed something so deep and meaningful that now this idea that you could just get bored of it or that they could get bored of you or these feel like superficial ideas. Like it feels silly to think that. And it's because you put the work in. And when we put the work into something and we devote to it and we show up and there's all of this growth and progress and depth, of course you don't want to sabotage it or just change your mind.
并且你得到了照顾，你们培养了如此深厚而有意义的感情，以至于现在觉得“你可能会对他/她厌倦，或者他/她可能会对你厌倦”这种想法，听起来就像是一种很表面的想法。就好像觉得这种想法很傻一样。这是因为你们为这段感情付出了努力。当我们对某事付出努力、全身心投入、积极面对，并且伴随着成长、进步和情感的加深时，你当然不会想去破坏它，或者轻易改变主意。
The rhythm stage, interestingly enough, actually is quite short-lived after you. the power struggle. So usually after the power struggle, we have that, that, you know, the power struggle can last forever. People can actually stay married for decades. They'll just live and die in the power struggle. That sounds awful. Yeah. Do not let that find me. And then, and then if we do make it out, though, the rhythm stages is short. It's usually another six months or so, sometimes even three months before we move into the devotion stage. And the Devotion stage is where we start to really move into long-term commitments. We start thinking about like, okay, marriage and children, maybe even like building a business
有趣的是，在你度过权力争夺阶段之后，相安无事的节奏阶段其实持续时间相当短。所以通常在权力争夺之后，我们会有那种……你知道的，权力争夺可以持续很久。人们甚至可以维持几十年的婚姻。他们就这样在权力争夺中浑浑噩噩地过日子。听起来真糟糕。是的。千万别让我落入那种境地。然后，然后如果我们真的熬过来了，节奏阶段其实很短。通常再过大约六个月，有时甚至只有三个月，我们就会进入奉献阶段。奉献阶段是我们开始真正迈向长期承诺的时期。我们开始考虑，比如，结婚生子，甚至一起创业，
together, these really like long, long-term commitments because, you know, you can get to a space where it's like there's a, you have kids, it's a lifelong commitment for the rest of your life, right? So you have this space. And in the commitment stage, you'll see that we feel that we're in this rhythm. We're coming out of the rhythm stage. We know how to navigate hard things. There's a trust in each other, that we can move through hard things together. And there's a security in that that then allows people to start really getting excited to plan for the future and to make bigger moves. And that's where we're in that real devotion stage. Both people will be mutually devoted in this stage. That's where you get like reciprocity. Both people know they have this sort of sacred belief in
这些非常长期的承诺。因为，你知道的，你会达到这样一种状态：比如你有了孩子，这是一生一世、直到生命尽头的承诺，对吧？所以你拥有了这样一个空间。在承诺阶段，你会发现我们感觉自己处在这个节奏中。我们正在走出节奏阶段。我们知道如何应对艰难的事情。彼此之间有一种信任，相信我们能够携手度过难关。这种安全感随后让人们开始真正兴奋起来，为未来做计划，并采取更大的行动。这就是我们所处的真正的奉献阶段。在这个阶段，双方会共同付出。这就是你所获得的互惠。双方都知道他们对彼此有一种神圣的信仰，
trust and harmony together. And that's the space that now people are like, okay, we've got this. I know this is the right person. I can see myself building a whole life with this person for the long haul. And that's really the prerequisite then, of course, to the everlasting stage. Okay, before we talk about everlasting stage, a couple of things I want to ask you about slash stick around in this space for a bit. I find it so interesting what you said by people trying to move from the power struggle phase into the devotion stage without moving either through the power struggle stage or the rhythm stage. This is, I have seen this. People are like fighting, having terrible issues and they're like, let's move in together. Let's have a base. Let's have a
共同建立信任与和谐。这就是让人们开始觉得“好吧，我们搞定这一切了，我知道这就是对的人，我能看到自己和这个人共度余生、相伴到老”的空间。而这当然是迈向永恒阶段的先决条件。好了，在我们谈论永恒阶段之前，我想问你几个问题，或者在这个话题上多停留一会儿。我觉得你之前说的话非常有意思：人们试图从权力争夺阶段直接跳到奉献阶段，而没有经历权力争夺阶段或节奏阶段。这种情况我见过。人们一直在争吵，面临着可怕的问题，然后他们却说：“我们同居吧，我们安个家，我们要个
baby. And I'm like, if you, if this is hard now, imagine how much harder it's going to be when you have additional financial pressures, when you have a living creature that you have to take care of, like a baby. I just feel like it just is so difficult to navigate with those like additional struggles. Speaking of partners, I'm just on a call. Wait, you can come in. Hi. Let me get back to what I was saying. Like, yeah, if you think things are hard now, like when you have additional financial pressure,
孩子吧。”而我的想法是：如果你们现在的生活就已经这么艰难了，试想一下，当你们有了额外的经济压力，当你们需要照顾一个活生生的生命（比如婴儿）时，情况会有多难。我觉得在有这些额外挣扎的情况下，事情真的很难处理。说到伴侣，我刚好在通电话。等等，你可以进来的。嗨。让我回到刚才的话题。我是说，是的，如果你觉得现在的生活很难，那么当你有额外的经济压力时，
when you see each other every single day and you haven't learned how to fight yet because you live together or have a baby together, like, it's going to get so much worse and so much harder. 100%. And honestly, exactly what you said is like one of the truest things. So so many times I would see people stuck in the power struggle, don't know how to navigate it. They're a couple of years in. And they go, okay, let's have a baby. And honestly, it's almost like trying to put a sense of novelty on something that requires vulnerability. It's like, let's do a new big thing together. And I would see countless, countless times, quite honestly, couples who would come in and they had, you know,
当你每天都能看到对方，却还没有学会如何争吵（因为你们刚同居或刚有了孩子）时，情况会变得更糟、难得多。百分之百。老实说，你刚才说的真的非常正确。我曾无数次看到人们陷入权力争夺中无法自拔，不知道该如何应对。他们在一起已经好几年了。然后他们说：“好吧，我们要个孩子吧。”老实说，这几乎就像是给一件需要极度脆弱和坦诚的事情，强行套上一种新鲜感。这就好像是在说：“让我们一起做一件新的、轰轰烈烈的大事吧。”坦白讲，我有无数次看到这样的情景：有些伴侣来找我咨询，他们已经……
because I obviously ran a busy practice back in the day for quite a while. And people would come in and they'd say, Taise, we're here to do counseling. We've broken up. We had a baby. And, you know, we are a couple years into clearly what was the power struggle. And they had a baby hoping it would be the save ball. And instead it broke them down, right? And broke them up.
因为我以前经营过一家相当忙碌的心理咨询诊所很长一段时间。人们会来找我，他们会说：“戴丝，我们来这里做心理咨询。我们已经分手了。我们有个孩子。而且，你知道的，我们在一起好几年了，这段关系明显正处于权力争夺期。”他们生了个孩子，希望这能成为拯救这段关系的救命稻草。但结果却把他们彻底击垮了，对吧？导致他们分道扬镳。
And so you can repair those things at that point, for sure by learning the tools and the power struggle stage that you need to. But so often people, A, have no idea that there's different stages of relationships and B, think that they're going to solve it by just adding new things. to do instead of actually navigating the core problems. And so, yeah, I just absolutely could not agree more with that. Yeah. Okay, we're going to take one more short break before we talk about the final stage, the everlasting stage. So stay with us. We'll be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
所以，到了那个地步，你当然可以通过学习工具和在权力争夺阶段所需的技能来修复这些问题。但很多时候，人们：A，根本不知道感情有不同的阶段；B，以为只要通过增加新的事情去做就能解决问题，而不是去真正直面核心问题。所以，是的，我绝对不能再赞同这一点了。好的，在我们讨论最后一个阶段——永恒阶段之前，我们要进行最后一个短暂的休息。所以请继续关注我们，我们马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out,
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人展开对话，带你抛弃那些充斥在健康产业中不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，
on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在苹果播客、iHeart Radio应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex In. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一切的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都能聊一整天快克，只是想让你们知道我的意思。我是说，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
我们现在还把“艾滋病”这个话题摆在桌面上，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。我不认为对黑人群体来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人群体而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里·方丹、雷恩·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输的游戏。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要。你是个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是纯粹地去做一个好人。和我，科尔·盖恩斯一起，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你在这份特定测试中篡改了两次，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never. mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要去招惹乡村女孩。你在玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女朋友们》中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都
dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Okay, so you're at the devotion stage. You know, you're very happy. You're committed. Maybe you're engaged in it, you know, you're engaged and you feel like this is the one forever. There is another stage, which is a very happy. You know, you're committed. There is another stage, is the everlasting stage. And my question for you is, does everyone from the devotion stage get to
和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们把事情掌握在自己手中。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。好了，所以你来到了奉献阶段。你知道的，你非常快乐。你对彼此做出了承诺。也许你已经订婚了，你知道的，你订婚了，并且你觉得这就是那个能相伴到老的人。还有另一个阶段，这是一个非常快乐的阶段。你知道的，你们做出了承诺。还有一个阶段，就是永恒阶段。我给你的问题是，所有处于奉献阶段的人都能进入
the everlasting stage? Or why would people in the devotion stage still choose to break up or have a breakup occur to them before they get to everlasting? Such a good question. So I would say the only major reason that I've ever seen people break up once in the devotion stage is because of some sort of external event that's extremely painful that essentially causes an identity crisis in one or both people, and now for everything they built sort of gets destroyed. So it sounds very dramatic and kind of harsh. But honestly, once you're at the devotion stage, almost every person ends up in the everlasting stage. They start actioning these things out. But let's say, for example, that one person, and I'll tell a story, there's some sad ones,
永恒阶段吗？或者为什么处于奉献阶段的人在到达永恒阶段之前，仍然会选择分手或者经历分手？这真是个好问题。所以我想说，我见过的唯一一个让人们在进入奉献阶段后分手的重大原因，是因为某种极其痛苦的外部事件，这本质上导致了一人或双方的身份危机，现在他们所建立的一切几乎都被摧毁了。所以这听说起来非常戏剧化，而且有点刺耳。但老实说，一旦你到了奉献阶段，几乎每个人最终都会进入永恒阶段。他们开始付诸行动。但假设，比方说，有个人——我要讲个故事，其中有一些悲伤的故事，
you know, of people who I saw over the years who were in the devotion stage and then broke up. And, you know, in one particular case, this is one of the less sad ones, but in one particular case, one person lost both of their parents in a year, right? That's the less sad one? That's the less sad one. Oh my God. That's a tragic one. I know.
你知道的，关于我这些年来见过的那些处于奉献阶段然后分手的。你知道的，在其中一个特定的案例中，这是一个不那么悲伤的案例，但在一个特定的案例中，一个人在一年内失去了双亲，对吧？这是不那么悲伤的？这是不那么悲伤的。哦，天哪。那是个悲剧。我知道。
Sorry. I should have said like a trigger warning ahead of time because it's sad. But truly, like, you know, and what happened is that person then spiraled into this really deep depression. And then they ended up in a space where they weren't showing up for the relationship. They were kind of angry. they had a chip on their shoulder. They didn't know how to communicate what they needed from this place of depression. They knew how to communicate and navigate other things from earlier,
抱歉。我应该提前发个触发警告的，因为它很悲伤。但真的，你知道的，发生的事情是，这个人随后陷入了非常深的抑郁中。然后他们进入了一种无法为关系付出的状态。他们有点愤怒。他们心怀怨恨。他们不知道如何从这种抑郁的状态中表达他们需要什么。他们知道如何从早期的阶段沟通和应对其他事情，
but in this depth of what they were experiencing, they were like, what am I experiencing? What am I feeling? And so I actually ended up working with this client who came to me to heal from a breakup after that. And they didn't know about the life cycle of relationships. They didn't know about how to process grief or there's sort of a lot in there. But those types of situations where there's something really tragic and extreme that causes a situation. person to not even know how to navigate their own lives. And then they can't show up for the relationship. And then we can backslide into, you know, back in the power struggle and then break up from there if there's something really big. If there's not something really big, generally once you're
但在他们所经历的这种痛苦深渊中，他们会想：我正在经历什么？我有什么感觉？所以我最终和这位客户一起合作，他们在经历分手后找到我，希望从中疗愈。他们并不了解关系的生命周期。他们不知道如何处理悲伤，或者里面有很多复杂的东西。但那种真正悲剧和极端的事件，会导致一个人甚至不知道如何应对自己的生活。然后他们无法为这段关系付出。然后我们可能会倒退回，你知道的，退回到权力争夺阶段，如果有非常大的事情发生，就会从那里分手。如果没有什么特别大的事情，一般来说，一旦你处于
in the devotion stage, people move into the everlasting stage. It's just about do we do the work necessary? Even people who have commitment fears. And you think, okay, there's this big fear of commitment. Would that be something that causes people to backslide? Even people with big commitment fears, generally at the point where you've learned to navigate things, talk things out, hash things through really well, those commitment fears essentially don't get a chance to see daylight over time because you're showing up with such a commitment to the relationship to get out of the power struggle stage that you're learning like, oh, commitment is scary because I'm scared of being trapped in a relationship that doesn't meet
奉献阶段，人们就会进入永恒阶段。这只是关乎我们是否付出了必要的努力。甚至那些对承诺感到恐惧的人也是如此。你会想，好吧，对承诺有这么大的恐惧。这会是导致人们倒退的原因吗？甚至连那些对承诺有极大恐惧的人，通常在你们学会了如何处理事情、把事情沟通好、把问题彻底理清的那个阶段，那些对承诺的恐惧基本上就不会再有机会见天日了，因为你对关系的投入是如此之深，以至于你走出了权力争夺阶段，并且你正在学习：哦，承诺是可怕的，因为我害怕被困在一段不能满足我需求的关系中。而当你懂得如何表达你的需求、谈论它们，并且在关系中得到满足时，人们对承诺的恐惧就会自然而然地消失。
my needs. And when you know how to navigate your needs and talk about them and then you're fulfilled in the relationship, people's commitment fear just happens to go away. at the same time because commitment fears are rooted in the fear of actually being trapped and not being able to get your needs met. So once we get into the devotion stage, you're extremely likely to move into the everlasting stage. It's sort of like the inevitable next step and the right of passage that moves you from there into the everlasting stage is all about in particular acting out the things that you were devoted to. So the devotion stage will sort of talk about them. I, you know, share ideas. We should have kids. We should, you know, move into this place. We should
与此同时，因为对承诺的恐惧根源于对被困住、无法满足自己需求的恐惧。所以一旦我们进入奉献阶段，你极有可能进入永恒阶段。这有点像是不可避免的下一步，而将你从那里带入永恒阶段的“成人礼”，完全在于将你所奉献的事情付诸行动。所以奉献阶段只是在谈论它们。我，你知道的，分享想法。我们应该生孩子。我们应该，你知道的，搬进这个地方。我们应该，
get married. We should do all these things. But what moves you into the everlasting stage is then that you're actually actioning them out. You have your first child. You know, you have your wedding. You do all these things. And so now the everlasting stage is actually about building and creating a life together. And it's marked by things like, you know, merging your finances, having conversations about how you want to invest your money in the long run or what things you want to spend your time doing or who's going to be, you know, taking care of the kids, what kind of parents we want to be.
结婚。我们应该做所有这些事情。但真正让你进入永恒阶段的是，你实际上正在把它们付诸行动。你们有了第一个孩子。你知道的，你们举行了婚礼。你们做了所有这些事情。所以现在永恒阶段实际上是关于共同建设和创造生活。它的标志是诸如：你知道的，合并你们的财务，就你们长期如何投资资金、想把时间花在做什么事情上、或者谁将，你知道的，照顾孩子、我们想成为什么样的父母进行对话。
It's marked by like these types of conversations that are much more rooted in how do we build, what life are we co-creating, what does this look like? And really moving from that space in particular is where you see you're definitely in that everlasting stage. Yeah. I also feel like I'm thinking now about those, like the snares, It's like the things that grab people and stop them from getting to devotion and everlasting.
它的标志是这类对话，它们更多地植根于：我们如何建设？我们正在共同创造什么生活？这看起来是怎样的？特别是从那个空间走出来，你会看到你绝对已经处于那个永恒阶段了。是的。我也觉得我现在想到了那些，就像是陷阱一样的东西。就像是那些抓住人们并阻止他们进入奉献和永恒阶段的事情。
And I feel like also that might be a requirement. I don't know if this is something you found as well to get through something that shifts your identity or shifts you as people, that you still are like, well, that's okay and we can grow through it. And I was like thinking about them. I was like, you know, maybe not being able to have kids would be like a really big one that you have to decide. Like can I do this on? Like is this really, you know, that would be really difficult. Like having a bit of like a mid like crisis, I'm sure happens.
我觉得这也是一个必要条件。我不知道这是否也是你发现的规律：要度过某些改变你身份或改变你作为人的事情，你仍然会觉得：“嗯，没关系，我们可以通过它共同成长。”我当时就在想这些。我想，你知道的，可能无法生育孩子会是一个真正巨大的问题，你必须做出决定：我能独自做到这一点吗？就像，这真的是，你知道的，那会非常困难。就像经历某种中年危机一样，我相信这种事也会发生在很多人身上。
to a lot of people as well, like losing, like, a career that, like, you were devoted to, like, a natural disaster. Like, I'm thinking about all these things and I'm, like, because they change you. And maybe they put you back into that stage as well. And maybe that's why you see, I'm thinking about, like, kind of my parents' friends now. And, like, my, like, older friends and these situations where it's like, we, something terrible happen or something so large happened that we actually came out of it as a different person, but some of them still get back together and they go back through this entire thing.
还有失去你曾为之奉献的职业，比如遭遇自然灾害。我想到了所有这些事情，然后我想，因为它们会改变你。也许它们也会把你带回那个阶段。也许这就是为什么你看到——我想到了我父母的朋友现在，以及我年长的朋友们，在这些情况下，就好像我们发生了可怕的事情，或者发生了如此重大的事情，以至于我们最终以一个不同人的身份走了出来，但他们中的一些人仍然复合了，并且重新经历整个过程。
So it's like, I'm thinking about like two instances in particular where I'm like, oh, this terrible, like, or not even, it wasn't terrible, it was just earth shattering. Like it happened and then, but they ended up getting back together and it was so interesting, like they went back through all these stages and they got married again and like all these things. I'm like, wow, it's so, it's so fascinating. So you just nailed it. So that's exactly what it is. So you can have these things.
所以这就像——我想到了两个具体的例子，我觉得：哦，这个可怕的，或者甚至不是可怕的，它只是天崩地裂般的。就像它发生了，然后，但他们最终还是复合了，这太有趣了，就像他们重新经历了所有这些阶段，他们又结婚了，所有这些事情。我就想：哇，这太，太迷人了。所以你真的说中要害了。所以这正是它的本质。所以你可以经历这些事情。
And the root of what actually can cause, because nobody really breaks up in the devotion stage, but we can backslide back into the power struggle. And the things that would cause us to back slide back to the power struggle is if you think of the power struggle as being rooted in our ability to communicate our needs, share our fears, open up vulnerably about our feelings, learn each other through that space, learn to navigate those things collectively. then what happens is if there's something, just like you said, a natural disaster or somebody not being able to have kids,
而真正可能导致——因为没有人真正在奉献阶段分手，但我们可能会倒退回权力争夺阶段——其根源在于：如果你把权力争夺视为植根于我们表达需求、分享恐惧、脆弱地敞开心扉表达感受、通过这个空间了解彼此、学会共同应对这些事情的能力，那么接下来会发生什么呢？如果有什么事情，就像你说的，自然灾害或者某人无法生育孩子，
100% of these things, it's actually rooted in one or both people having an identity crisis that then causes them, even though you originally did the work, it changed who you were as a person, exactly like you said, because you had an identity crisis. And now you're relegated.
百分之百的这些事情，其实都根源于其中一人或双方经历了身份危机，这随后导致他们——尽管你们最初付出了努力——但它改变了你作为一个人的本质，完全像你说的，因为你经历了身份危机。现在你被贬降了。
Just by nature, you're relegated back into the power struggle stage because now you have new fears, now you have new wounds, now you have new needs in the relationship because you became a new person, and the situation or event changed you enough, that the things you learned about the person in the power struggle stage
出于自然规律，你被贬降回了权力争夺阶段，因为现在你有了新的恐惧，现在你有了新的创伤，现在你在关系中有了新的需求，因为你变成了一个新的人，而这个情况或事件对你的改变足够大，以至于你在权力争夺阶段了解到的关于那个人的事情，
in your relationship have dramatically changed because they have changed dramatically. And so now you have to go back through this relearning stage, relearning to navigate, talking about the new fears, the new flaws. And if you do that, you'll then move back through the stages, then you progress again. But if we don't and if we don't know how to navigate ourselves, sort of like that client I mentioned who fell into that deep depression and came to me after they had already broken up with their,
在你们的关系中已经发生了巨大的变化，因为他们已经发生了巨大的变化。所以现在你必须重新经历这个重新学习的阶段，重新学习如何应对、谈论新的恐惧、新的缺陷。如果你这样做了，你就会再次通过这些阶段，然后你再次取得进展。但如果我们不这样做，如果我们不知道如何驾驭自己——就像我提到的那个客户，陷入了深深的抑郁中，在他们已经和伴侣分手后来找我，
and they weren't looking to get back together at that point because it was quite a while after the fact. But they didn't know who they were in that depression. And so they then didn't know how to say what they needed. They didn't know how to be vulnerable about what they were feeling or how to express it or explain it. And so they ultimately had to do a lot of healing and work within themselves to then be able to come back and be functional for a new relationship as a new person.
而且他们当时并不想复合，因为那是事后很久了。但他们在那种抑郁中迷失了自我，不知道自己是谁。所以他们随后不知道如何说出他们需要什么。他们不知道如何对自己的感受保持脆弱，或者如何表达或解释它。所以他们最终不得不在自己内心进行大量的疗愈和工作，然后才能作为一个新的人重新回来，并为一段新的关系做好功能准备。
Yeah, this is so fascinating. I could talk about this all day. I want to ask you like two final questions, though. They've just kind of come up for me. I'm like listening to this. I'm like, oh, what would the listeners want to know? Like, what are they thinking? The first thing I'm thinking is, can you skip any of the stages?
是的，这太迷人了。我可以一整天都聊这个。不过我想问你最后两个问题。它们刚刚浮现在我的脑海里。我听着这些，然后想：哦，听众会想知道什么？他们在想什么？我脑子里的第一件事是：你可以跳过任何一个阶段吗？
Because there are people who seem to really get to devotion really quickly. Great question. So you can speed them up, but you don't skip. So, you know, you'll generally see, for example, securely attach people who have like a very secure upbringing or who are earned. secure before getting into a relationship. They can move into the dating quite quickly, move through the dating. They know what they want.
因为有些人似乎真的很快就进入了奉献阶段。好问题。所以你可以加速它们，但你不能跳过。所以，你知道的，你通常会看到，例如，那些有着非常安全的成长经历、或者在进入一段关系之前就已经获得“安全型依恋”的人。他们可以相当快地进入约会，并度过约会期。他们知道自己想要什么。
They're a little more clear. They might move from dating into honeymoon quickly. And because securely attached people with healthy habits going into relationships, they naturally talk about their needs from the jump. They're a little more vulnerable earlier on. They're quite intentional. They have healthy tools already that equip them to navigate conflict. You'll see a very short power struggle stage.
他们更清醒一点。他们可能会很快从约会过渡到蜜月期。由于安全型依恋的人带着健康的习惯进入关系，他们从一开始就自然地谈论自己的需求。他们在一开始就更加脆弱坦诚。他们相当有意识。他们已经拥有健康的工具，使他们能够应对冲突。你会看到一个非常短的权力争夺阶段。
Secure people still go through power struggle stage. they just have a shorter version of it. And then if you're looking, okay, let's say somebody made a commitment within two months, so they went from dating into honeymoon. Honeymoon lasted a period of time, like let's say a year after the fact. And then power struggle may be another three months. Then you're in the rhythm, another couple months, and you're in the devotion quite quickly. So you can see a shortened time horizon for sure, especially if we date right, if we have really
安全型的人仍然会经历权力争夺阶段，他们只是有一个较短的版本。然后如果你在看，假设有人在两个月内作出了承诺，所以他们从约会直接进入蜜月期。蜜月期持续了一段时间，比如事后一年左右。然后权力争夺可能又持续了三个月。然后你进入节奏期，再过几个月，你很快就进入奉献期了。所以你肯定能看到一个缩短的时间跨度，特别是如果我们约会得当，如果我们在一开始就对冲突有非常健康的习惯，如果我们通过更脆弱地进行艰难对话并从一开始就定下这种基调来为成功做好准备。所以你可以看到一个缩短的版本，但人们仍然会经历每个阶段。甚至那些结婚的人，并且似乎从一个安全的基础开始结婚。所以假设有人因为宗教原因。比如我有一个朋友。他向他的妻子求婚，我想，大约是在六个月的时候。而且，你知道的，他们结婚了，他们有一段非常健康、充满爱的关系。但这是一个快速的转变，对吧？六个月求婚，很快就结婚了。甚至连他，处于这种情况下的人，他们结婚很早。他们有一个非常健康的基础，
healthy habits for conflict early on, if we set ourselves up for success by having harder conversations more vulnerably earlier and setting the tone that way. And so you can see a shortened version, but people will still navigate each of the stages. And even people who get married and seem to be married from a secure base. So let's say somebody for like religious reasons. I have a friend, for example. And he proposed to his wife, I think, around six months. And, you know, and they got married and they have a very healthy, loving relationship. But it was a quick, quick turnaround, right? Propose in six months, got married quickly. And even him, people in these types of situations, they got married early. They had a really healthy foundation,
但他们在某个时间点仍然经历了自己的权力争夺阶段的版本，对吧？当他们同居并结婚时，他们不得不花一会儿时间去磨合，进行那些更艰难的对话。所以你仍然会看到我们所拥有的每一个阶段。由于各种外部原因，有时你只是会看到一个更小的时间跨度。当然，这意味着部分“秘诀”和“技巧”在于，你希望提前做好疗愈，这样你就准备好以一种更安全的方式约会，因为它让关系的整个生命周期变得容易得多。再次说明，这也是为什么从统计数据来看，大约50%的人口是安全型依恋的，尽管这似乎呈下降趋势。但当你看到安全型依恋的人时，他们也报告说自己拥有最持久的关系，并且是最满足的，而且安全型依恋的人，他们……
but they still had their version of a power struggle stage at a point in time, right? When they moved in together and got married, they had to like navigate it for a minute and have the harder conversations. So you'll still see each of the stages that we have. You can just see a smaller time horizon for different external reasons at times. And of course, that means that part of like the hack and the trick is you want to get. you're, you know, your healing done right ahead of time so you're ready to date in a more secure way because it just makes the entire life cycle of a relationship so much easier. And again, it's part of the reason it's statistically, like statistics show that roughly 50% of the population
当他们进入关系时，他们倾向于留在关系中，对吧？因为他们早早就为这些阶段做好了充分准备。而且我认为他们在早期也做出了更好的选择。
is securely attached, although that seems to sort of be on a downward trend. But when you see securely attached people, they also report being in the longest lasting relationships and being the most fulfilled and securely attached people, they, um, they tend to when they get into relationships, they stay in them, right? Because they're well prepared for these stages earlier on. And I think they also choose better early on as well.
因为他们会想——我现在在想这个，然后我就想：哦，是的，是的，是的。因为他们不只是去追逐那个情感上不可用的人。你知道我的意思吗？他们会进行背景调查。
Because they're like, I'm like thinking about that and I'm like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Like, because they're not just going after like the emotionally unavailable person. You know what I mean? They vet.
完全正确。完全正确。这一切都融会贯通了。而且他们约会得很好。就像他们带着意图约会一样，他们不会容忍太多的废话。对吧？如果有人以糟糕的方式对待他们，他们会说：“抱歉，不，我不接受这个。”正因为他们这么做，他们为自己奠定了基础。
Exactly. Exactly. It all comes together. And they date really well. Like they date with intention and they won't put up with much BS. Right? If somebody's treating them in a bad way, they're like sorry no i don't i don't put up with this and so because they do that they set themselves up
在权力争夺中获得了巨大的成功，所以权力争夺不是那种被拉长、持久的事情，它只是雷达上一个简短的小波普，就像一个小小的路障，然后他们继续向前迈进。是的。好吧，我还有很多其他问题想问你，但是——我们需要结束这一集了。我的最后一个问题是，我们会向每一位来到节目的嘉宾提出的问题。我想我以前其实问过你这个问题，但我还是要再问一遍，那就是：有什么建议是你希望在20多岁时就知道的，而这与我们今天讨论的内容完全无关？天哪。太有趣了，杰玛，因为你一说出来，我就想到了，我确切地记得我会说什么，那就是你上次问我的问题。
for so much success in the power struggle so the power struggle isn't this big drawn out lasting thing it's this sort of short little blip in the radar that's like a little tiny road bump and they keep it moving yeah okay i have so many other questions that i want to ask you but like we we need to wrap up the episode my final question is the one that we ask every single guest who comes on the show i think i've actually asked you this before but i'm going to ask it again which is is what is the one piece of advice you wish you had in your 20s that has nothing to do with what we talked about today? Oh my gosh. It's so funny, Jemma, because as soon as you said it, I was like, I remembered exactly what I would say, which was what you asked me the last time.
当时我说要对自己多一些同理心。然后我有了这种闪回的时刻。但你知道我在20多岁时会说什么吗？其实我就说对我20多岁时帮助最大的事情吧，你知道的，我是一个……我是在混乱中长大的。我是……我是恐惧回避型的，我所有的这些创伤以及所有这些。作为一个孩子，我经历了很多你所谓的“不公正”，比如许多艰难的事情和许多非常、你知道的，相当创伤的情况诸如此类。直到我20岁出头的时候，我都紧紧抓着这些不放。我想：所有这些坏事都发生在我身上。没有人理解。没有人。这就是我对自己的故事。我经历了人生中的某种个人低谷，
And I said to be compassionate towards yourself. And I had this like flashback moment. But you know what I would say in my 20s? And I'll actually just say what helped me the most of my 20s is, you know, I was somebody who was like, I grew up in chaos. And I was. I was fearful avoidant and I had all these like wounds and all of it. And I had a lot of what you would call injustice as a kid, like lots of hard things and lots of really, you know, pretty traumatic situations and things like that. And when I was until my very early 20s, I held on to that really tight. I was like, all these bad things happened to me. Nobody understands. Nobody. And it was my story of myself. And I went through a sort of personal rock bottom in my life where
当时我想：天哪，没有人会来拯救我。我必须拯救我自己。我必须振作起来。而我紧抓着所有这些艰难的事情不放，然后为自己麻木自己、逃避事情、生气、或者，你知道的，带着创伤到处走、心怀怨恨找到借口，当我这样做的时候，我伤害的只有我自己。我们知道，我做的最关键的事情之一——谢天谢地——就是我想：哦，我必须意识到，我对生活的个人责任就是我的自由，发生在我身上的事情不是我的错，但改变它们是我的责任，只有我能做到这一点。我真的投入到学习、研究和付诸努力中。显然，就像所有收听节目的每个人一样，都在学习、研究，
I was like, oh my God, nobody's going to save me. I have to save me. I have to show up. And me holding on to all these hard things and then justifying that I should numb out or hide from things or be angry or be, you know, carry my hurt around and have a chip on my shoulder. I'm only hurting me when I do that. And we know, one of the most pivotal things that I did that I, you know, thank God for is I was like, oh, I have to realize that my personal responsibility for life is my freedom and it's not my fault that things happen to me, but it is my responsibility to change them and only I can do that. And I really poured into like learning and researching and doing the work. And obviously like everybody who's listening to the show is learning and researching and
并且，你知道的，为此定下基调。我认为投入到真正的努力中，如果你出身于一个关系艰难或经历过坎坷的背景，这不必成为你余生的全部故事。它完全可以变成：好吧，太棒了。我选择为自己的心理状态承担责任，尽管我并没有选择它，但我会努力去重新布线、重新调理、努力疗愈。我真的认为那是人们能送给自己最好的礼物。它为未来开辟了一个由你说了算的世界。这就是自由。
you know and setting the tone to do that. And I think pouring into really doing the work, if you come from like a hard background of relationships or tough things, it doesn't have to be your story for the whole rest of your life. It can literally be like, okay, great. I'm choosing to take responsibility for for my own conditioning, even though I didn't choose. it and work to rewire, work to recondition, work to heal. And I really think that that's like the greatest gift that people can give to themselves. And it just opens up the world for like a future on your terms going forward. And it is freedom.
这就是自由。这就是自由。好吧，再次感谢你来参加节目。我一定会把你的学校、你的课程、你和你的YouTube频道的链接都放在那里。无论通过什么方式、在什么地方能找到戴丝，我都会确保你能找到。因为我热爱你所做的事，我热爱你的工作以及你解释事物的方式。
And it is freedom. And it's freedom. Well, thank you again for coming on. I'm going to make sure that we leave all your links to your school and your courses and you and your YouTube. Like every way and which way and which place you can find taste, I will make sure that you can find it. because I love what you do and I love your work and how you explain things.
所以再次感谢你。一如既往，你可以在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast。确保你一直在关注我们。现在是12月中旬嘉宾月的中间。我们还有很多其他非常棒的嘉宾，我已经等不及让你们听到他们的分享了。所以如果你还没有关注我们，你可不想错过收听他们的节目和听他们分享。但直到下次，保重，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。
So thank you again. As always, you can follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Make sure that you are following along. It's the middle of December guest month. And we have so many other fantastic guests that I cannot wait for you guys to hear from. So if you are not already following us, you don't want to miss listening to them and hearing from them as well. But until next time, stay safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself.
我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的方法。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。在《Look Back At It》播客中。
And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
对于1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何和我们的朋友、同僚喜剧演员，
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians,
以及最喜欢的作家一起熬过这一切的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人群体来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你们是在与一位懂得他在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional
有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcast.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在这份特定测试中篡改了两次，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸裂了。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的检测，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。这花费了一大群互联网侦探的力量才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网深陷》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《情网深陷》播客。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that. Trust your girlfriends.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是这样说。相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。